hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
tim poole and you're listening to the
latest episode of civil war cast because
apparently it's the only thing we're
ever going to be talking about now that
uh donald trump is confirmed to be under
criminal investigation for obstruction
of justice and violent in the espionage
act and you've got the uh was it a
former former cia director jack former
cia director hayden cia and nsa oh both
uh insinuating trump should be executed
so uh there was that and there was a guy
from msnbc who also made the same
assertion and uh just wow
wow okay that's nice so we'll uh we'll
we'll talk about that and then wow it's
a memetastic friday so trending on
twitter is
there's a
donald trump is accused of sharing the
nuclear codes in a fundraising email and
it's fake obviously
and then fox news shared a photo of the
judge who signed the warrant with uh
gelane maxwell on the plane and it's
obviously fake but these people are
freaking out so at least we can have a
laugh about that while everything kind
of just falls apart so we will and a
whole lot of other crazy stories alex
berenson release a story on a substance
that the white house sought his
banning on twitter and so he's got the
receipts and this is
huge so uh yeah
dark days indeed before we get started
my friends head over to timcast.com
become a member if you want to support
our work you'll get access to the
timkest members only uncensored show
monday through thursday at 11 pm as well
as tales from the inverted world and
we're gonna have the new i believe cass
castle is officially launching next week
and then we've got we it's a weekly
series that's going to be a combination
of behind the scenes and kind of just
like a fictionalized funny take on um on
the culture war and on the work that
goes on here so
you know there's that there's also pop
culture crisis in chicken city check
those shows out smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends joining us today to
talk about civil war is jack vazovic
what's up jack posobik here host of
human events daily also senior editor
over at humanevents.com human events
daily now
also available real america's voice
we're on at 10 p.m so i asked them i
said we need to fill that gap in between
because tim cast has eight to ten and
then there's that period and then the
eleven o'clock goes up i want to fill
that gap so we are the tim cast night
watch over at 10 pm human events daily
at 10 p.m 10 p.m so like you watch the
show and then you talk about it's like
it's like the it's be recorded it's okay
i was kidding except for tonight but um
we're gonna record it here right now
yeah yeah of course
right exactly so civil war anyway we
have hannah claire brimley hanging out
hey i'm hannah clara i'm a writer for
timcast.com
oh okay hi hey hey anna claire uh you
ever go by hannah by the way no you just
have to play
uh ian crosslin what's up dudes let's
rock and roll
and uh lydia is sick today unfortunately
so chris is here hi i'm chris hey chris
anyway let's knock out of you chris
here's the uh here's the story big mouth
on chris gosh guys guys
earlier today
i'm reading this alex berenson thing
about how the white house uh
basically instructed or demanded his
suspension and i'm like wow this is a
huge story and then all of a sudden i
see people talking about like hey you
see the former head of the cia calling
for trump's execution and i was like
what and so i looked i was like okay
he's not really calling for it he's just
saying it should happen basically and so
here's so
i'm just kind of out of it like um
last night someone mentioned that joe
rogan said on the show
he thought i was crazy when i said civil
war was coming and now he thinks i'm
right
and so uh they sent the clip to me and i
played it earlier on my morning show and
it's just kind of like nam what jack
called it like tim pool is right night
or whatever i don't know what you were
saying simple is very weak right weak uh
yeah but you know it's it's just like
it's easy to call it things that you get
right i got a lot of things wrong i you
know to make that clear but here's the
story trump is under investigation for
violating the espionage act after fbi
recovered 11 sets of classified
documents from mar-a-lago full warrant
is unsealed but ex-president insists he
declassified everything which he can and
so uh
i thought they said he was uh got the
nuclear documents what happened to that
story washington post what are they
saying now it's a broad search warrant
it's not it's not the search warrant
says all
all documents for the entirety of his
presidency so
the the piece that we have here and
humanevents.com actually dropped this an
hour before anybody else today we when
we got our copy of it remember the story
has changed every single day of the week
because at one point we were it was the
newsweek piece the newsweek piece says
two
high-level justice officials tell us
they're authorized authorized to tell
newsweek that the department of justice
had absolutely nothing to do with this
raid that it was all the fbi it was
completely driven by them it was rey
these guys out of dc these numbskulls
they were the ones behind it and even
though by the and they just grudgingly
admit way down at the bottom of the
newsweek article that and by the way of
course there is a grand jury in dc
that's you know looking up to indict the
former president for crimes but don't
worry about that and then garland comes
out the next day and says it actually
was him who authorized the raid then the
night before we're told but he oh but
what does garland say to us garland says
to us
it was narrow in scope okay narrow in
scope immediately he walks off stage
he's this this deranged you know he's
like five six i called him a um i called
him a deranged eunuch and
we get the leak to the washington post
the washington post says nuclear codes
right nuclear documents nuclear
basically
we don't know if it's pretty pertaining
to weapons in the united states or
elsewhere right so it's like they didn't
know actually right well and here here's
the thing right you know um
kind of the no cap response to that is
that
obviously the nuclear codes get changed
on a very regular it's very frequent
basis could you imagine if it's like i'm
no longer the president for over a year
now
but we're not going to change the launch
codes change the locks he's he's in the
well this is you know this is the big
meme on on sort of like mega twitter
right now is that it's now we've gone
from nuclear or
ultra maga it's a nuclear maga so that
that's right that's right trump never
never gave up the nuclear codes he's got
him down there at mar-a-lago baron trump
is gathering the fizzle material he's
got four he's got four nuclear turbines
already he's working towards 10. um you
know they're they're targeting rehoboth
beach you know all the rest of it so the
memes have just been flying absolutely
flying and uh unlike the missiles which
are not flying hopefully though we'll
keep an eye we'll keep an eye on all
that but no they they said that it was
narrow in scope but then we get so when
i posted the documents this afternoon i
said wait a minute it says right here
all documents
from the president's archives from
january 20th 2017 all the way to january
20th 2021 well that's the entire scope
of his presidency so that's why you're
seeing things in this inventory sheet
which we also posted that say things
like the roger stone pardon is in there
or like letters between himself and
emmanuel macron
that's that's every single document it's
a fishing expedition
but that's okay because because the
judge that signed off on this is one of
the best judges in the country just
definitely not connected to any scandals
or he did a really good job helping
epstein's lieutenant he did a wonderful
job well it was interesting because
here's what happened okay he on he
started as an epstein prosecutor and
then in the course of prosecuting
epstein he realized that it was a
wrongful prosecution and that he had to
help out and do the right thing not for
himself tim but for the good of the
country and the good of abstinence so
the victims he resigns from the us this
is dead serious resigns from the u.s
attorney's office
and then goes to work for epstein's you
know organization represents
not not jack that represents the pilot
represents the lieutenant those in order
to help save them freedom those actions
represent america basically john he's
basically the new john adams what is
this so they they raided trump and now
he's oh wait wait and just and now he's
a judge
[Laughter]
what was the justification for this
search warrant thought then we still
don't have it we actually
actually still don't have it the warrant
was like give us everything so here okay
okay okay so here's you know joking
aside here's here's the serious part of
it
there is another missing piece to this
and that's the answer to your question
because you're reading this thing and
we're looking at the seven pages of the
warrant in the property inventory and
you're saying wait where's the
where's the so what why can we just
authorize fbi agents to go do this right
and so they're supposed to be an
affidavit and the affidavit is what's
given to the judge to get him to
authorize the search warrant we don't
have that yet
they haven't released it
jack
civil war
i mean
and tim here's so here's like don't sell
yourself short right because
when you're when you're talking for as
many hours a week as we do right
we're bound to get a lot wrong we're
bound to make misstatements we're bound
to just have predictions that don't pan
out etc but your big prediction of the
where where all of this was going over
the last five six years you've always
said this is headed towards and maybe
you know maybe tomorrow
joe biden comes out crying and says
am stopping this charade donald trump is
a good man and we cannot allow the
weaponization of the doj i hereby resign
and and then everyone cheers and biden
supporters that's not what i'm hearing
pink hats are hugging maga hats in the
street
people are they throw them in there
together
what's that meme of like blm and mega
like you know fist bumping for the
better yeah no that's not what i'm
hearing at all in fact what i'm hearing
out of dc is that you're hearing a lot
of democrats are going to the white
house saying okay the way to fix this is
to lean into it because because what
they're what they're from this line of
thinking which might sound completely
crazy and by the way joe biden's down
there in south carolina he's definitely
not going to jekyll island by the way
that's no no nothing which word you know
nothing ever happened there and um
and
they're saying that you have to lean in
because since you raided him right
now it looks political but if you indict
him
then it looks like you're just following
the facts
right as if they had a plan all along
because it was an actual crime and
it so they're actually people advising
president biden right now to indict
donald j trump so and
just if you look at as caustic of a
situation
that this country's been in for the last
six years even for the last six months
right i think we all
could just pull back and you know
take off the red hat take off the pit
whatever hat you know and just say
that's probably not a good place we want
to take people into so this episode from
of the rogan podcast comes out last
night someone super chatted at us saying
joe said he thought tim was crazy now he
thinks he's right and uh what i didn't
realize until
this morning well i was like wait a
minute they pre-record those shows right
joe didn't even know at the time of
recording that that some dude went to an
fbi building and tried to bust through
the bulletproof glass shooting at fbi
agents before fleeing and being killed
when he recorded that segment that had
not happened it hadn't even happened yet
and so um
it's kind of crazy because i'm wondering
what's going through joe's mind now with
that news hitting after he said this a
few days ago he's probably thinking like
well i was right about thinking tim was
right now right because that's that's a
whole whole new level of crazy of course
people
people on the right think this was a
false flag
i i look i understand exactly what
people believe it and i'll put it this
way
the fact that people believe this guy
in cincinnati was a false flag
shows and it's widespread too like
hardcore trump supporters across the
board are like no way that's real just
goes to show the disdain and distrust
for the federal government especially
with you know what we saw with ray epps
so people are just not ready to believe
well and you you're following the
whitmer case because that's coming out
right now the next iteration of it and
julie kelly has been doing such great
work on this and they're having to admit
in court that fbi agents or fbi assets
were planting explosives in the trunk of
cars you had another fbi informant and
i'm just following julie's reporting
they said the fbi informant was not only
staying in the same hotel as the target
not only staying in the same hotel room
but yes as you can imagine she was
sleeping in the same bed as the target
so just full on not just honey pot
operations like the eric swalwell style
with fang fang no no no no this is honey
pot operations to treat you into trick
you into actually committing domestic
terrorism acts and then prosecuting you
i want to jump to uh this next story
here from the national review sounds
about right ex-cia chief michael hayden
implies trump should be executed for
taking classified documents
so jack um civil war
yeah again you know you've got people
like michael hayden general michael
hayden head of the cia someone who's
actually had people executed right
overseas
uh in drone strikes going ahead and just
using that same type of language
meanwhile by the way the right is
supposed to we are being told we have to
tone down our rhetoric because of this
guy in cincinnati but you've got the
general out there saying this michael
hayden is saying it on from the cia from
the fbi when how many weeks has it been
since gen er justice kavanaugh and his
family were nearly shot to death by a
crazy left-wing redditor who had in his
backpack uh flex cups and duct tape he
had a nine millimeter glock on him and
this was the same guy who had posted you
saw they pulled his internet searches
right
oh yeah yeah and he was looking for
other
well he was looking for other justices
and then he also googled how to be
stealthy
uh assassin skills and where best place
to stab someone wow
i was i was actually assuming that was
gonna be like mixed in there was gonna
be something like about you know
beautiful women in your area or
something like that uh actually yes so
he posted on reddit
and came out as mtf
and was and was looking for someone to
cuddle with
on
i forget exactly which subreddit it was
but was posting in those in those chats
that looking for a cuddle said hey i'm
really into movies and i'm looking for
someone who's also into movies and i
just want to cuddle i don't it's you
know it's like friends but it's kind of
my own thing that i'm working on
yeah everybody needs a good cuddle come
on 100 mtf is male to female that's
right okay all right so here's what uh
michael beschloss tweeted he tweeted
rosenbergs were convicted of giving u.s
nuclear secrets to moscow and were
executed june 1953
and a bunch of these outlets like media
was like they never actually said
anything about trump in the tweet he's
just sharing some fun facts and then if
you look at his series of tweets which
he like says a bunch of stuff that
tweets this and says a bunch of stuff
it's all like trump may have given
secrets out or something like that what
if trump gave an adversary nuclear code
so so before we get too far down the the
rabbit hole on this just
fro from a basic overall standpoint
that doesn't apply to the executive that
doesn't apply to the commander-in-chief
so trump when we were talking about this
before we came on air but trump when he
was the president joe biden currently
barack obama when he was president for
all presidents right
they have
plenary
declassification authority the same way
that he's plenary pardon power which i
actually tweeted this morning that you
know um you know the people who said
that trump should have pardoned uh no
don't pardon assange don't pardon
snowden don't pardon old bricks why
because then you might have trouble with
the doj yeah that look how that worked
out right you know so but by the same
token he can declassify whatever he
wants whenever he wants because he is
the authority there's no authority over
him for that imagine donald trump goes
to meet with vladimir putin and he's
trying to negotiate denuclear
demilitarization denuclear
nuclearization which has been u.s russia
policy for 50 years so he goes to putin
says look i'd love to tell you about how
we're going to de-escalate but it's all
classified i can't i can't negotiate
with you like what the president
literally has to negotiate with the
president of other countries about
nuclear strat like all the time weapons
right this has been
going back to reagan gorbachev going
back to carter the the salt treaties i
mean this obviously they're going to be
discussing nuclear weapons posture
because that's a jfk and the cuban
missile crisis and then the missiles
that we had in turkey that was like the
secret agreement um
it would be fun if they retroactively
retroactively go back in time and charge
all presidents with treason for
discussing our weapon stock pilots so
you're saying we should convict jfk yeah
back in time dig up his corpse
if it's available
did his head disappear his brain
disappears happen after he was killed
there was like a con
theory that his brain went through
witnessing because it was too much
evidence about how he got hit they said
it was one bullet in the back of the
head but they're like actually it was
multiple bullets but we can't find his
brains i don't know how any person will
be able to take chunks of brain and be
like this was more than one bullet yeah
pearl jam row brains of jay it's a song
of theirs
all about that anyway who's got the
brains of jfk when we're at the point
where you have an msnbc host nbc staffer
historian
and a former cia director
insinuating trump should face execution
well what's the story here so he said by
the way could you imagine if i like me
and charlie kirk get up at a turning
point event and we just start talking
about uh dr fauci and
joe biden any of any of the binders
anyone by name with with this type of
language all right we're done we'd be
completely done we'd be we'd probably be
arrested by the time we got off january
26 2021 marjorie taylor green indicated
support for executing prominent
democrats in 2018 and 2019 before
running for congress there you go just
all this indicated and suggests
potentially that crap like what just
potentially what's the before we get
going to her i mean we could look at her
stuff too but what did the guy say that
said he implied that he may i saw a
quote that said like that may be cool or
whatever he said sounds about right
sounds about right and it's all out of
context and it's like implied it's not
out of context
michael
has a thread where he's like what if
donald trump was selling our nuclear
secrets then the news came out from
washington post which was basically fake
news saying they were looking for
nuclear documents and he said i'm
re-upping this tweet then he said
so he tweeted that before the article
yes oh oh he tweeted before the article
came out wow then after the article came
out he said i'm re-upping my tweet here
to highlight this don't want to be
overly speculative made some other
comments about donald trump and nuclear
documents then posted this
and then posted more about how how
imperative is imperative we must get the
search warrant to understand what they
were looking for basically saying before
the article came out donald trump may
have had nuclear weap codes or secrets
and he may have been selling them oh no
this story's suggesting he did we
executed people who did that before we
better get that search warrant now and
then the cia guy said sounds about right
but like in what context did he put it
on the twitter thread or did he yeah he
added it right saying sounds about right
yeah
that we but what is he talking seattle
what does he do which by the way that
was actually
by the way
the rose that was how that was the
building the because
back in the 1950s the the ability to
build nuclear weapons was a closely
guarded us secret
and
only we had it obviously it was it was a
huge advantage of of us over the soviet
union and for the soviets even after
they got it later it was a huge
advantage for them over communist china
it's one of the reasons that led to the
sino-soviet split because the soviets
never wanted chairman mao to have
nuclear weapons but then the they get it
anyway the u.s exacerbates this etc etc
but the rosenbergs the whole point was
that they were selling how to build
nuclear weapons which is totally
different than just saying you know hey
we've got six thousand but we'll break
it down to five thousand if we can sign
this treaty and right you know also i
mean if trump had nuclear codes they
were defunct they were from a year ago
and that what would giving ancient
nuclear codes to someone do because they
have different codes now why would he
why would he it's just do you know about
trump's red button no the reason the
story is i saw the meme of the button
being smashed no but so okay so when
trump was lock the door when women
walked in his office no no no he didn't
work for msnbc
um
matt lauer right um
and then so no so trump had a red button
on his desk when he was president and
that button was attached to a
a wooden box
and he would have people into his office
at the oval office and when they were
having the meeting he would just in the
middle of the meeting just randomly go
oh sorry no i know i know everybody's
looking at that at that button nobody
wants to put that button here i'm just
going to push it away and he'd push it
away from himself on the desk
and then trump pushes the button and
then and then just like slides it away
and then everyone's and then he's like
no don't worry about the button don't
worry it's just it's just there and then
he would go back and you were saying you
know and they'd all be that because he
would know that they'd still all be like
totally fixated on the button and then
and then every once in a while he might
just kind of lean over and then he'd
just kind of like tap it
and then everybody's freaking out in the
middle but you know they're not trying
to say anything because it's the oval
office you have to have the decorum etc
and then eventually what would happen is
a side door would open up and then
somebody would walk in
with a diet coke for him that's what it
was
it was to order a diet coke is that real
dead serious no dead serious get a diet
coke button in the olaf go pull it up oh
dead serious i feel like tim is now like
what am i going to get what's my button
going to be tim's like i want a red
button what would you have for a red
button tim ah
new beanies
a bottle of water maybe bottled water i
got my water i can get it myself i don't
really need one
coconut water no
i don't know maybe some bacon or that we
should get e in a graphene but actually
made out of graphene okay press a button
yes and then bring up two pieces of
crispy bacon not too crispy but crispy
enough do you like it blackened like a
chard no no no no no i like it
like the fatty parts would be fatty but
the rest should be pretty good i don't
know you can fold it and kind of get it
together yeah i like it disintegrating
but i like it just right before
regarding bacon fat like what's a
healthy amount of daily all of it as
much as but like just from what i strip
i pour the whole thing into my eggs yeah
you should and look how much weight i
lost yeah yeah you've i even in i i
think it's been a couple of weeks since
i was here but even even from then to
now you've definitely lost weight
interest and i've done it by pouring
bacon grease into my eggs effect your
fit and your eyes huge fat cat face i
really want you to write a diet like
book now without bacon fat the wondering
the wonderful powers of bait and bacon
huge thing of butter i i put a fourth
cup of cream into my coffee real butter
real oh farm butter better be real buddy
yes
i can't describe the smell it is like
when you cook with store-bought butter
and then you go by farm butter it's
insane the smell is so dramatic you
realize you've been lied to your entire
life yeah it's like you it's like waking
up for the first time and you're like
right it's almost like water that farm
butter it's so pure and clean yeah yeah
it's amazing it's like when i'm when i'm
in eastern europe we just then we were
in poland and then or from uh visiting
tiny's family it's like that that's what
everything's like over there they don't
real food
getting um having milk in europe was
crazy it tastes so different yeah it's
so rich real it's so rich let's
let's let's deal with the well to deal
with the fat though i mean we can't go
overlook that the fact that fat has been
lied about so many years in this country
fake news by the industry but the fake
news of you want to talk fake news let's
talk about the food pyramid right yeah
you know
so this is in any time i get a chance to
talk about this it's it's just they're
they've been lying to you they've been
lying to you for 50 years about fat
bread and grain and pasta they wanted
you to eat that is the primary source of
diet that's freaking absolutely not
i got that all growing up that
propaganda we all did
we all did it was that and that acid
rain and quicksand were like everywhere
yeah apparently i saw a new article said
that rain on earth is no longer safe to
drink because of micro plastic i don't
know what they're called pfct i'm just
like dude get out of cities okay
regarding some people get out of cities
butter is better outside of the city you
have to leave so hold hold on real quick
i'll throw it in real quick there's
there's a little there's a farm near us
and they have a little farm stand and
you walk up and they give you butter
they they did like themselves they put
in the thing they seal it they hand it
to you it's amazing couple bucks it's
like
and it just it will your mind is blown
by how delicious you know joanne's been
making butter did she tell you about it
my mom got a butter churner yeah i kind
of want to get a butter churn yeah uh
you were gonna say something about civil
war well yeah whether or not it's a
civil war i think it's semantic one side
knows how to make the butter one side
guns and butter right guns and butter
i've been thinking lately that it's more
of a fifth generation world war and that
i'm what i'm concerned about is that
they're going to use the united states
as the proxy and it's going to be an
asian versus european war and they're
gonna just
let it happen here and they'd be happy
to see us go they'd be happy to see this
country get leveled get taken over get
dis dissipated whatever well china
doesn't want us
destroyed the same way they don't want
taiwan destroyed because we're their
market right we're their consumers you
must consume uh so if you if they lose
the united states and and yeah they're
certainly building in with with europe
and they're making their inroads all
over the place in europe but you know
you lose the united states you lose your
biggest customer yeah but rebuilding
would we be in desperate straits and we
need to buy that steal from someone if
we had to rebuild too i know what you
mean though i don't think anyone really
wants the the infrastructure blown up or
anything but i think
ultimately england we think of them as
our friends france as our friends but in
the heat of the moment i think they're
all going to look at the united states
and be like you know what warmonger
you're on your own and if we need to
fight china in kansas we're going to
fight china in kansas
let me jump to the story uh from twitter
actually
they have this running in their what's
happening uh tab and it exemplifies
perfectly that the civil war may
actually be people of cognitive ability
and people of limited cognitive ability
because this uh twitter says manipulated
image of fundraising email from former
president trump contained fake nuclear
codes fact checkers report
if you needed a fact checker to tell you
that donald trump did not email the
nuclear codes to people then you are in
the uh latter faction i have just
mentioned this is actually quite amazing
let me let me pull this up from newsweek
because there's a very prominent leftist
podcast i guess i think mueller she
wrote is the left podcast new donald is
fundraising by giving us nuclear codes
this is an effing joke to him and i i
know
they understand trump is is is doing a
gag but this is not even real
they they thought
they believed it
they didn't believe that trump was
actually getting out nuclear codes but
this is a meme
the new codes are 15 25 50 80. can i
count on you to donate 15
dollars eighty 25.50
if you make it recurring we can nuke
beijing tonight is this like not
realizing someone photoshopped that and
then put it out or is it not realizing
it was a joke no because a manipulated
image no i i know i could tell you that
that's a manipulated image because
that's not what trump fundraising emails
look like have you seen these yeah
they're all saying the fbi is coming for
you give me money yeah they're all like
they're all like what is wrong with you
why haven't you why haven't you signed
in yet for this month why haven't you
this these high pressure tactics
and i don't know why but for some reason
it's it's it's actually it's it's gross
it's actually gross i'm not a fan and i
don't i don't like it and then you need
to stop it i get i get fundraising
emails from from some and it's like
unpaid balance yeah i'm just like
dude it's crazy yeah they're just like
and you realize that they're just
preying on certain people they're just
straight up praying on people it's just
it's just i'll tell you what's crazy
independent fox news airs edited photo
of trump raid judge with gelane maxwell
because they can't just say meme edited
photo
it says what i mean to say
and was fox news making a gag is that
what was happening well i do want to
point out here that
they didn't edit in the the easy time
and the oreos that's an actual those are
actually in the photo of the epstein
judge um that's actually real that's
obviously actually glenn maxwell but in
reality this is a photo of epstein and
her rubbing epstein's feet what they've
done here is take out epstein i guess
his torso and replace that with the
judge that was epstein's lawyer that
before was epstein's prosecutor and then
yeah
hannity says i think it's actually a
picture of jeffrey epstein with somebody
putting the judge's head on there i'm
guessing i don't know no it's not just
his head that's the point though no but
but on fox news they weren't saying like
look at this stunning image of the judge
they were like look at this photo is
that that's hannity i'm sorry he's like
that's epstein isn't it okay so right so
kill mead was um i didn't actually watch
it but from the article it looks like
because kilmeade was hosting for guest
hosting for tucker yeah um and tulsi
gets hosted the night before
oh wow and um and in the handoff
kilmeade is keeping the joke going so
he's saying i don't know that looks like
the plane that uh that looks like it you
know and entity's doing his whole well
you saw i'm sorry but when hannity was
like you know i used to say it was 99 of
the fbi was good but maybe that's down
to 95 come on man still saying that 95
he just said it this week 95 of the dude
take off the cia pin just come on man
did you see the uh jimmy door nina
turner thing oh yeah and that was the
brand of joy gray thing so for those
that aren't familiar you've got the
jimmy dore thing jimmy dore is basically
saying if the right is now coming out
and saying the fbi is corrupt we should
embrace that and say yes thank you
welcome to the fight
and i'm like exactly and then you have
bran i think it's brandon joy gray on
she's on the hill right yeah she said
basically the same thing that we all
think the fbi is corrupt if the right is
not saying the same thing we've won like
okay let's move forward right yeah but
then you had nina turner who was like
just ragging on jimmy calling him you
know what right wing and racist or
whatever see i used to like nina turner
because she used to call out like the
joe biden democrats back in the day kind
of from the um from the bernie sanders
camp and then it seems like which he has
like some show now or something and
and now she just won't do that she was
responding to jimmy maybe we can pull up
this uh twitter thread at some point and
with identitarian politics like yeah uh
something about jimmy's attacking a
black woman yeah black black woman i'm a
woman but when you look at the full
thread jimmy started that by saying a
leftist something something something so
he identified yeah he played identity
politics jimmy jimmy she responded with
it jimmy pointing out that the left has
typically been anti-fbi but now aren't
is different from saying you attacked me
because of my race but that's
identitarian calling someone leftist
like when you start off a conversation
with them it's not it is you're you're
making giving them an identity and
that's no he's saying like that's their
position like you have to be able to say
like a group of people he's not saying
you're a terrible lefty because you
think that like well i'm not bringing in
criticism of it you're you're
identifying them as a part of a group
but that's not that's not an identity
identitarian is identity-based
governance
right well i mean you could have
identitarian governance or you could
just have identitarianism like all the
all the black shirts all the gray shirts
that's ideological that's not identity
and i would just strongly recommend you
just look up what editorialism is
because you are just absolutely you're
talking about like big eye
identitarianism governance is that we're
talking about because you can be an
identitarianist without being involved
in politics
okay identitarian specifically refers to
the physical attributes of identity and
governance based on such saying
someone's of the last or mental i mean
mental attributes physical and mental
attributes yeah what you identify as so
it typically refers to like yeah see
identitarianism is a pan-european
nationalist far-right political algae no
i'm not talking about the political
ideology now you're reading the
politicized like left argument the big
eye the big eye identitarianism movement
okay apparently that's a real movement
uh
this is a anyway anyway jimmy started
off by calling her a leftist which is
not a terrorist which is not i that's
just political wholly disagree with you
guys but you're wrong what you're saying
is like if i were to say the entire
state of wisconsin has been calling for
years to defund the fbi that would be
like saying that's identitarianism which
it's not wisconsinites yeah
anti-wisconsinites
no wisconsin is
like the entire state i love wisconsin
by the way it's baby that's right if i
was like all the ladies you get stand up
that's identitarianism no
of course it is you're judging someone
by a piece of their identity judging
them it's just saying this group of it's
just
i think i think you're mixing up
identitarianism with just identifying
yeah just i don't think the verb of
identifying vegetarian is identity plus
government right well you're talking
about the big eye movement no that is a
moment no no no no that's what the word
means you're gonna have to pull that up
and show me definition wise because i
just i don't i would encourage you to
research this before making a political
point that doesn't
work i'm not making a political the
issue was that jimmy dore said she used
the lowest like the lowest of identity
politics to attack him because he said
the left has always opposed the fbi
we should be embracing the right when
they say this like you know and bran and
joy grace said margery taylor green is
right and i'm like here here sounds like
sounds like some some logic and some
more moral principles to me and then
nina turner was just like jimmy dore's
insulting well this is black woman this
is the dynamic you see you've seen
between like mega and the left and sort
of like the populist left for so many
times because it's always like you'll
get a couple a couple people from both
sides start flirting with one another
and then other and then you'll have
people like jimmy dore come along and
say hey wait a minute we agree with what
you're saying or hawk newsome when he
when he got up at the maga rally uh i
was like the mother of all rallies in dc
i think it was 2018. i was there and he
said look you guys are against corrupt
politicians we're against corrupt cops
could you agree with us on that and
people started cheering said yeah of
course
right and so you'll have these moments
where people start kind of flirting with
each other in sort of the two populist
camps and then along will come somebody
from the establishment or doing the work
of the establishment and saying hey you
guys need to break that up right now
yeah but it it tends to be
that um
like nina turner in this instance right
as the establishment you're concerned
trolling you're straight up concerned
trolling but the problem is
you you end up with people who embrace
like on the left they they end up
believing this nonsense like the nuclear
documents thing was widely believed by
these p these establishment shills and
it just it was not true or to the extent
that was not true is the search warrant
was it was broad it was for literally
all documents so to claim they were
looking for nuclear documents okay i can
argue they're looking for dogs the
document said anything relating to
trump's presidency so i could have
written a story saying the fbi was
searching for information about the cats
that trump had talked about well yeah
because i'm sure at some point he did
and it's in the record somewhere he
mentioned a cat that's a stupid story
it's nonsense they all believe it and so
i'm just sitting there and i'm like
these are the people who believe jesse
smilet
okay i don't take my political cues from
them
and that's so when when you get the two
populist factions and they're like hey
we agree on these things and then all of
a sudden an establishment person comes
up to break it up and they say something
nonsensical like justice millet and the
left believes it
it's like okay dude look we're kind of
like i don't know how you bring the
sides together when you've got one side
who's going to believe that or kind of
like when you had a cv show on cnn
called crossfire
where
uh tucker carlson and somebody from the
left could sit down and argue but at
least they were talking that was that
was that cnn i believe was cnn wow and
then jon stewart comes on and starts
yelling at both of them for having a
discussion and then 20 years later
somebody has to go and confront jon
stewart in the street and say john if
you want this burn pits bill done we got
to work together will you shake my hand
and he did yeah he was yelling at you
that was crazy he was not happy with me
at first what what did you say to him
that the first thing you said like what
did you say to him i said you're short i
said no i did not say he was short i
didn't i didn't attack him i didn't
tucker did
tucker said many things about it but but
tucker and he have a different history
than he and i do um
it i'd never met him before and
you know the jon stewart thing
was i went up to him and yeah i was
recording but i was not live
and i just wanted to have a record for
so that you know nobody could accuse me
of doing something i didn't do and
raheem kassam was there and
i said look you're you're attacking and
smearing all the republicans as being
against this burn pit bill you're saying
you're against the republicans and the
context is this there's this there was
and it has been passed now and signed
into law
this bill for benefits for for veterans
who were injured by the burn pits and
the burn pits uh were funny enough
classified material um was being burned
because when you're not the president
you have to dispose of this but if
you're in the field you know it's not
like you can follow some specific
process you just got to get rid of it
and then move on so hence burn pits um i
had people even in my unit that would
come back from afghan girl i knew came
back from afghanistan um because of the
black smoke that would come out of this
stuff uh nails started falling out
fingernails toenails hair was coming out
in clumps just you know it does stuff to
your head i've got another buddy who's
had issues with his um his lungs you
know if he goes over a certain altitude
he has trouble finding flying on
airplanes and stuff so burn it's bad
very bad
but jon stewart was running around at
first
doing this huge media tour saying
republicans hate the vets republicans
hate the vets and that's why they won't
vote for this thing when in reality if
you look what the republicans were
saying people like ted cruz and and pat
to him not even a fan of pat toomey um
he's my senator right and they were
saying look well the cbo score came back
and said you know there's this 400
billion dollar discrepancy between the
house and the senate bills and we want
to deal with that right and
that's not what sort was saying and so i
went to him and i said look john
you're so close on getting this bill
done will you sit down and meet with ted
cruz or any of these guys
maybe i can even help facilitate that
with you know whatever phone numbers i
have in my rolodex to make that happen
and i don't think he heard me because he
saw me and he you know recognized me and
was like oh well this is that guy from
twitter that doesn't like me so he just
went off he just started completely
going off
and that's what you saw on cnn
and then
later on what was really interesting
though
is and to his credit right i stayed back
i talked a bunch of people tim jensen
dude from um grunt style we chatted for
a while and then john saw us talking and
said well hey i like this guy and if he
likes jack maybe i can go talk to him so
jon stewart comes back up to me
and has this kind of said hey man i'm
sorry about that you know i thought you
were trolling me i wasn't really
listening to what you were saying i was
just kind of responding to what i
thought you were saying
and you know if you want to work
together to get this bill done let's do
it i said that's great john and you said
that to me now in person but before you
said all that stuff on camera so would
you do a video with me so that people
can understand that we're going to work
together and he did to his credit he did
this this is the problem right here we
pull this up uh ground.news jon
stewart's bias oh this is perfect 59
left it's not all that bad i mean john
uh uh
does get some conservative some some
right-leaning news in there he goes on
fox he goes on newsmax and um and uh he
praised trump when he when trump was it
was the 911 first responders i believe
trump was working on getting relief he's
talked about um the the wuhan lab he's
talked about that oh yeah yeah yeah so i
think i think it's really interesting
that you can see the integrity of an
individual
in their bias fact checker
isn't that fascinating yeah john stewart
it's like he yelled at you abruptly and
then you had to break through that
barrier but you guys eventually shook
hands and found something there we did
and it's like
you look at his biased blind spotter on
ground news and
59 left leaning
and his attitude and behavior is like 59
left-leaning you know what i mean just
enough to let it go right right just
enough where he like actually does pull
back a little bit and have that
conversation with you
i was looking at a tweet from uh
stephen marsh we've had on the show he's
the guy who wrote the book the uh the
next civil war i think it's called
and he said something to the effect of
like
being pro-police but anti-fbi how will
the right phrase this one and then and i
sent him a link to an article and i'm
like the right has been ragging on
police since covent right yeah no covid
and the when the churches and all right
yeah and then i showed him his blind his
blind spot or bias it's like 80 percent
left no conservative news bro get out of
your bubble
it invariably when i see these people
saying these things that are just wrong
wrong wrong
they're always their media consumption
is always dominated by the law do you
think moderate is also a bubble because
mine is like 80 white 80 moderate or
something like that and i wonder if i'm
in a bubble as well because no you're
just outside of politics well doesn't
this also so
mine's totally skewed right because
i work with post-millennial and human
events so i'm sharing their events their
articles said the same thing right right
right
that doesn't mean that's the only thing
i'm reading
no of course of course yeah it's not
perfect so it you know i feel like it's
kind of skewed so yeah i'm posting that
right you see post military human events
are my top three sources but in many
cases i'm either editing those articles
or working on those articles and yeah
i'm definitely to be biased towards ones
that i uh hey look at that hey very nice
look at you oh now look at that left
look at you left this look at you
leftist what is this tim cass is a top
three news source all right and tribal i
don't know
right my point is your top news source
is not timcast michael
elon
musk no my top source is tim cast
right but no i'm saying for you as a
person is that your top news source um
a little bit but i wouldn't say top i
don't know if i have a top news source i
was thinking it may be twitter and
that's why can you consider twitter a
news source
should be your top news it's a really
great site i actually think it's too
slow for me
like
but it is that's why i'm posting stories
no i actually think this so somebody
asked me this once uh as an in an
interview and they said what's your top
news source and i just said i don't have
a top news source i follow topics and
they didn't know what i meant i was like
well if i just see something trending or
if there's something i'm interested in i
just type it into the search bar on
twitter and i see what's going on so if
i want to know about you know the like
there's a whole mexican cartel war going
on right now down in jalisco then
hardly it's never trending but you can
just go to twitter right now and type it
in and go watch a bunch of videos from
it uh people getting shot up in little
caesars and
just just crazy crazy video auto zone
but it's not but i'm not sharing it it
just happens to be something i'm
interested in because it's crazy citizen
journalists is it usually people with
like a lot of it citizen journalists
yeah and and so my point being though is
that i'm not going to an outlet for that
i'm just following it on twitter i was
thinking lately last time maybe twitter
is an outlet because i'll even see in
like news articles they'll quote twitter
posts section 230 baby and they're but
yeah but they're like uninhibited they
can do whatever they want they can guide
the news they can say this story is not
going to show up on twitter uh if you
search for it this one's going to go to
the top of the algorithm twitter is a
source because there's tons of
journalists that are just on twitter
exactly so i follow a bunch of people
that are like field reporters and stuff
like that they're on twitter i get
breaking news because i'm on that
platform but this doesn't show twitter
but that doesn't show that right media
poly
oh right it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't show who you follow and things
it shows you
based on i think there's a couple
different organizations that rate the
leaning of various news organizations
and then they ground news applies that
to their blind spotter or whatever
but um i think if you were to even look
at my bias 40 left 25 center 27 right i
think most people probably agree with
that in how i act you know what i mean
that is pretty close for you right right
right like not die hard trumper but
sometimes being like well you know i
don't know right yeah
yeah i got a hard time
uh like pegging down your political
things you just seem kind of like
general but i mean you talk more about
people what you would consider on the
right or in the conservative movement
for whatever reason i don't know but
like it's more interesting is that
because of where you found yourself in
life or or um was it easier to work with
people like that what what kind of
pushed you in that direction you know i
don't know i mean like
i'm i mean i'm catholic that's kind of
where i come from but that has nothing
to do with my my news um that's also one
of the reasons that i think that you
know sort of the
the libertarian movement while it seemed
interesting to me i could never quite
could never quite you know go fully into
it because that's just not where i come
from um
and
when i look at you know when i look at
people on the right and really 2016 just
kind of what blew that up and at that
point it wasn't even about right or left
it was just who's telling the truth
right who's actually just just going up
there and saying you know is this a
movement of the people versus dc or is
it
you know is it uh is it just a typical
election of left versus right and where
you are getting no obviously not right
you know this is a populist movement and
that's the side i'm always going to be
on i got really turned off by the
democratic establishment after 2016.
that was hard to watch what they did to
bernie sanders yeah so we went we would
go out there at the dnc with jill stein
with the bernie people and we covered
all that stuff and i covered that with
just as much attention as i did anything
on the right too
jack i have a question for you
let me just uh i'm taking a note real
quick jesus reminds us no my question is
have you have you ever met would win in
a fight have you ever met elizabeth
warren uh
i have to think about that i don't think
so you didn't didn't uh if you did would
you ask her
i don't even know how to say this this
story is so what do you mean just get it
out to him just get out on the plane to
new hampshire the night of the iowa
caucuses warren said quote everyone
comes up to me and says i would vote for
you if you had a penis oh yeah you know
i did say that
yeah that not now now that you remind me
yes
but everyone was saying it yeah no well
good no because everyone is saying it so
i just you know
of course i'm going to follow the crowd
yeah yeah you're not going to not say it
to elizabeth warren this is such a weird
statement like
what what did she say this in the
context too
it's like she's trying to assert
patriarchy and misogyny or whatever oh
okay
right a nonsense statement i'd like you
all to just consider this for a second
she said everyone quiz a quote everyone
comes up to me and says i would vote for
you if you had a penis that means there
are old women going up towards going i'm
a big fan of this why not vote for you
if you had to penis
i really don't think that's happening i
really don't think
everyone so like an 18 year old guy
walks up to her and says that to her
well you also see this though with
and this this might be to give i'll
throw you boney this is a little
identitarian um even though it's about
gender because
they're trying to act as if your
your reproductive organs are the only
difference between men and women
like this this you know the physical
external attributes are the only
difference whatsoever there are no
biochemical differences there's no
spiritual differences there's no uh
physical differences other than that
which we can see imagine if you had uh
in your local community is a very
serious problem with pickle jars
okay all right right well then i am
polish well
well there you go yes and now it's it's
someone might actually go close with one
and be like i'd vote for you if you had
a penis because can she open pickle jars
for the publisher
remember hillary remember hillary's the
pickle pickle gate right no the jimmy
kimmel you don't remember this no
this was the whole okay so in 2016
hillary's health was the big meme and
everybody kept saying what's up with
hillary's mel health and then there was
the problem with hillary stools and
because hillary would always appear on
stage with a stool so we were talking
about hashtag hillary stools hillary
stools are appearing everywhere hillary
whenever hillary appeal appears hillary
stool will appear with her and then
everybody was saying that she can't get
through an event without without having
to sit down at some point so she goes on
jimmy kimmel
man people forget how crazy 2016 was she
goes on jimmy kimmel and he kind of
brings all of this up and says he goes
madam secretary would you would you
would you open this pickle jar for us
and then she does and they make this big
meme out of it but then it comes out
that the pickle jar was actually
pre-opened
of course even before she did all this
yeah it was a staged it was a yeah yeah
i just want to get to the point where
she opens the pickle jar where's the
pickled juice it was a rigged pickle jar
it was rigged tim
look at that oh look at this look at she
she looks like um
this is how crazy 2016 was i'm telling
you guys same haircut
yeah like if you weren't around for the
great meme war and salute to the great
meme war veterans out there if there's
anyone's in the chat
you know who you are you guys are nice
zero
you see this is this is this is the fake
news at play
because you know in this country and we
have a serious issue with pickle jars
that are tough to open
they staged a pickle jar opening to
convince the american people hillary
clinton was the right person for it but
you know what the american people saw
through the lies and they knew she
couldn't actually open a pickle jar
probably because she collapsed on the
side of the road had to be thrown into a
van now this was this was before the
collapse that's what i mean like this is
why people were like they saw three
weeks before yeah
this is also a strange way to be like
hey it looks like you're having trouble
you might have weakness in your legs
you're getting fatigue please open this
pickle jar like they should have done
the whole interview standing if they
wanted to dispel the rumors but instead
they're like let's test out something
else
i don't understand if you go to the
doctor complaining of heart pain and he
checks your ears and he's like well
you're not deaf and you're like cool so
i'm fine like it it doesn't make any
sense to me i was gonna say in response
to the elizabeth warren um you know why
uh she apparently didn't get elected
serena williams announced this week that
she is like open to retiring and
i thought she did retire she is still
playing i think after the season she's
gonna retire she uh said one of the big
things was you know one of her lines
from it was if i was a man i wouldn't be
writing this like her career because
she's talking about having more kids and
you know there are like some other
factors in her life she's over 40.
i think that
a lot of women
are told that your problems come from
not being a man but i think what
actually the problem is is you're being
pushed into careers and into lifestyles
that don't allow you to be female right
like i didn't vote for elizabeth warren
because she didn't have a penis i didn't
vote for her because i don't believe in
what she believes in but she's told
actually if you were a man you would
have gotten elected if she were a man
with the same principles i still
wouldn't have voted for her yes i still
would have got thrown under the bus
because she sucks i'm not voting for dr
oz because he sucks yeah i don't care if
he's a republican and a man and all that
and that's all the right parts like they
just suck so who are you gonna vote for
then
uh
for that one i'm i mean i might write in
my dad like i did when we might and then
what happens when fetterman wins
then is he even alive right we haven't
seen this guy in three he knew he hasn't
been on the trail for three months oh he
was sick he was like seriously he had a
stroke yeah he stroked out and he and he
has not been seen in public for three
months well you know
he cuts these videos and he's like you
want to talk about health let's talk
about fetterman's health um this guy
like he'll he'll do these videos with
his wife where i guess he's at his house
but when he talks it's all like it's all
wrong the speech is all disjointed um
but he does not seem well can you open a
pickle jar john fetterman open up a
pickle jar or else resign from the raise
immediately yeah but i want to test that
pickle jar first yeah we need it yeah
ian's gonna test the ian will be the
pickle jar tester the official one of
pennsylvania i'm appointing you what
we'll do is we'll go to supermarket yes
ian will choose the pickle jar off the
off the shelf at random that's right and
then hand it to me but we have to make
sure well we have to check it though
because sometimes kids do it don't
people do it yeah dogs with good senses
of smell to check smell the vacuum yeah
make sure that it hasn't no leaked
bacteria everything make sure it's still
fresh just check the top you press the
top yeah you just check the top yeah it
goes my concern with this elizabeth
warren thing i've been thinking a lot
about hyperbole i feel like especially
with us doing a show like being you know
displaying journalism stuff it's really
important not to be hyperbolic the term
all the time gets used unfortunately way
more frequently than i like you seeing
get used all the time yeah i almost said
it you see but i'm trying not to be
hyperbolic and this is elizabeth warren
saying everyone comes up to me that's
hyperbole some people probably have but
not everybody and it's like
we don't need to prove to people with
zell that everyone and everything all
that like
we made it now we just got to be honest
and be accurate wouldn't she have been
flying to was a iowa on a plane with the
rest of her campaign so is she saying
she's not well the members of her
campaign are coming up to her being like
if we'd vote for you but
not only that but we're talking about
her primaries so she's talking about
democrats let's be fair too obviously
when she's saying everyone
she doesn't mean literally every single
person of course but even when we take
her statement at face value it's still
insane
that okay obviously on her staff
obviously not every single person she
meets but that there are women and and
and old men who are like well i wish i
had a penis like i really just don't
believe that
at all
and it's no surprise that democrats do
well it's kind of like you know you also
wonder if there's an element of
projection here where
people are saying things to her but in
her mind she keeps thinking that over
and over and over because that's her
biggest it she thinks that's her biggest
challenge i think she's totally over and
over again that's what i think is the
problem a lot of women are said like
well the thing is if you were man
opportunities would be different from
you and that's just like
in some ways you could understand the
logic but it's not the reality let me
let me let me explain to the ladies
the problem here
you see
when you get um
when you get anti-meritocratic hiring
practices like in california did they
pass a law a while ago it's like the
board has to have a woman on it or
something like that yeah
you're seeing this everywhere right so
you'll end up i've been in meetings like
this
and you have people i've been in
meetings like for documentary production
stuff and there's some women brilliant
and they'll say like here's my plan
here's what we're gonna do and i'm like
wow that sounds amazing like uh right
now we're working a documentary with a
woman and it's it's some of the best
i've ever seen uh alex moyer yeah i'm
just i'm like this is great stuff but
then what happens when you go into these
meetings where they've hired a woman to
fill a quota and then everyone's talking
and they're like
if we're going to sell more widgets we
need to improve the widgets and then the
the the quota a higher you know
individual regardless of if it's a woman
or not but but a lot of women will say
something that's totally out of line out
of context or doesn't align and people
have nothing to say but okay that won't
work okay but let's try something else
and then they go they're they're i'm the
only woman here and they're telling me
my ideas are no good that's it's because
i'm a woman and it's like no no it's
because you weren't qualified when you
were hired there are plenty of
circumstances i've been in where people
were were all qualified and some men
weren't qualified and they were brought
on because they were the son of somebody
or something i've been in a ton of
meetings where it's like i'm like why is
this guy here like oh well
his uncle which which is and and by the
way if you are speaking of female
director manimilius right so her father
is john millius
you know world famous director
red dawn conan rome you know so much
stuff apocalypse now and a great writer
as well
but she's had to you know come out on
her own
and but but she's never come out and
said you know i made a friend of mine
but i've never heard her once say
something like oh
well
i'm a female and you should let me have
this and oh my dad is so and so it's
like no it's i'm gonna do good work and
i hope you watch it the end you know
it's interesting i was just thinking
about being an actor the only time i've
ever really been type cast for something
is when i'm acting and it's like i want
they're like hey we need a blond male
that's 28 years old i'm like well that
was me that's perfect i'm so i
understand now hollywood is so
identitarian and you see such nasty
propaganda coming out of that because
that whole industry is built around
identity and about finding someone to
fill the role for the character type
you're looking for not for who's the
best unfortunately sometimes you get the
best actor put into the role but way too
often so that that entire industry is
brainwashed to think this way and then
they affect tv and movies and then that
affects politics i think it'd be
interesting if we just started being
like hey look like
you're okay you kind of have a
background in whatever our company's in
but we need a woman to sit at this table
so we'll just pay you a bunch of money
to hang out maybe don't talk that much
like do you think anyone would ever be
like okay sounds good i've got a family
at home i'm just trying to free money
why not i don't think that sounds
horrible no no it doesn't but but what
this is all running up against and the
idea of a meritocracy runs up against
what is essentially the the civic
religion in the united states and that
we aren't allowed to talk about the fact
that people are different that people
have differences that some people are
smarter than others that some people are
more qualified than others that some
people are able to perform physical
tasks with greater ability than others
etc etc because we have this idea that
everybody has to be the same and that if
someone's a little bit different oh
don't say that because you're going to
hurt their feelings and this is
essentially the civic religion in the
united states at this point is the way i
put it
imagine you're on the third floor of a
burning building and there's thick black
smoke filling the air and you're
crawling on the ground and then all of a
sudden the door slams open boom right in
front of him and you're like oh save me
and then as the smoke clears a 5 foot
100 pound woman says i've got you i'd be
like oh situation not busting but now
imagine the same scenario the door gets
kicked in and a six foot six
tall super ripped pure muscle guy goes
i got you you'd be like yes me
i would i would i would beg for a large
powerful man to be on the other side of
that door please a a large handsome
chiseled bearded man with bulging
muscles to say specifically handsome
yeah he doesn't want an ugly guy to save
you no ugly guys no no my point is like
i don't care save me give me function i
don't care as long as it's it look it
could be a massive like well you know
what guys
but you're so
okay totally got me on that one but um
uh but uh
you know what they're trying to add this
to now they're trying to bring
this
you know non-merit
hiring into airline pilots
they're trying to push this now in and
saying it's not diverse enough it's
because there's not there's it's not
female enough it's not you know they
don't like the they want more um you
know racial and ethnic quotas aren't
enough they they're pretty soon they're
going to say it's not
lgbt enough or whatever they're going
they're going to start adding things
that dilute the pool of our airline
pilots which is just a job that
obviously needs to be the person who's
best for the job period no questions
asked jack i'm so i'm sorry that that
was incredibly bigoted of you of you to
say how many
of the uh uh airplane crashes have been
have been piloted by females huh not
enough not enough
overwhelmingly male 1
there's actually a joke about the combat
go look up the navy the combat death gap
it's like 98 percent well go look up
what is that some some guy wasn't the
best yeah that's always really bothered
me that not enough women die in combat i
don't understand why you guys aren't
letting us serve our country the same
way hey man i love you you see those
videos where yeah how many how many oil
rigs and you know miners
there's the oil rate would be much
prettier if you let women on it they're
yeah maybe but there are those videos
where women were reacting to the senate
trying to
put women in the draft and they were
like i didn't know feminism meant that
no stop stop let me just tell you
something
real quick
the the military in this country is
struggling to recruit and you know what
that means
it means draft so if something really
does crazy does happen and we get a
world war iii or whatever they're gonna
be drafting you and ladies that means
you too equality right this is why i was
against feminism always if i get drafted
because of feminism i'll be really mad
what is this when's this story from uh
the 1990s oh the 90s oh what's the story
yeah i double first female combat pilot
died the very i wanted to double check
it i was about to say u.s navy this
happened in the navy the very fir and i
was like i'm not going to say this
before i i'm gonna fact pre-fact check
my so i'm gonna pre-bunk this i'm gonna
pre-bunk this pre-bunk the first combat
qualified female naval aviator aviator
actually did die in a plane crash i
watched top gun there was a lady in that
plane bro and she did a good job see
here's my problem with top gun maverick
um my biggest the biggest problem with
the movie that everybody uh seems to
have missed and i don't get it is that
the movie takes place in a country that
doesn't exist because it's as if the
america if the 80s never stopped in the
2000s never happened
and yeah if if the 2000s never happened
then sure you could have top gun
maverick but they did happen and so that
that military doesn't exist anymore
especially especially with the navy
after tail hook so what does that
explain it so tail hook was this idea
that
there was this conference and
they busted a bunch of people ncis got
involved and you had you know sexual
harassment claims sexual assault claims
many of which were true by the way but
the navy's response to this was we are
going to basically de-testosteronify
the entire force and anyone with you
know people get sensitivity training and
we have to integrate the genders um not
long after that was carol holckren was
pushed in as the first female aviator
and and eventually we're at the point
now where you have women serving on
submarines which never happened before
and
this huge push against basically anyone
who had that sort of you know that the
reputation of the navy right the
reputation of the sailors got the girl
in every port and is getting drunk when
they pulled in for you know a port call
or something and they wanted to do
everything they re
reverted the force or reoriented the
force completely away from that towards
this sort of like you know the 90s
modern male kind of image and you still
see that today and you see you see that
all the way up to outside the navy but
um the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff general milley where i don't know
if you saw his draft resignation letter
he was like crying as he wrote it you
know teardrop it
on human events but
where it feels like it's i can't allow
the military to be like this i can't be
a part of this you are you are
politicizing the military you are using
fear and i will no longer be a part and
i'm like this is
using fire and ire and this was
do you even understand why world war ii
happened why didn't trump fire that guy
because i i don't know drum ship fired
all of these people fauci on down yeah
he's naive
he just just get rid of him i don't know
man
i feel like i feel like if anything
that
trump
came into the situation thinking that
it was like you know eisenhower that it
was the 1950s and i'm the president bam
boom snap my fingers something happens
this thing gets nuked these troops get
pulled out from here this this guy goes
and gets blown up uh this just that
things just happen because you're the
president you order them to happen
without realizing that there's this
layer now there's this layer that's
called the administrative state and you
can use whatever you know you call it
the deep state you can call it the
bureaucracy whatever the idea is though
that
you go back to woodrow wilson because he
laid this all out exactly how he wanted
to institute it that
when the
darwinists first started coming up when
they said we have organisms we have
survival of the fittest we want the
state then so wilson reads darwin and
says we need a state that is
operating under this model of survival
of the fittest and because the founding
fathers didn't know about darwin they
didn't know about the voyage of the
beagle they couldn't possibly have
understood the importance of the
survival of species and the importance
of the survival of the fittest and so we
need a new form of a state we need a
state that is organic that exists
outside of the branches of government
outside of congress outside of the
people's representatives who are elected
and so they came up with this new
bureaucracy the bureaucracy which we can
see nowadays
is tied into academia is tied into
education it's tied into corporations
and you see this idea of the expert
class which is titan this is how you get
by the way
you know an anthony fauci who is an
unelected bureaucrat who has power over
our entire country and all the people of
congress and many of the people the
white house completely just divert
everything to him and this happened in
the trump white house for a very long
time now eventually you know people like
scott atlas and others got in there um
peter navarro was a big part of this of
course fbi is going after him as well
and
that's what they're trying to do so ian
and we were talking earlier about this
idea this idea that can the president
declassify anything
i mean
that very question is the way they want
you thinking they want you thinking that
the bureaucracy has power over the
president and that the president is only
given his power by you know the largest
and the generosity of that no absolutely
not our system is that the
commander-in-chief is elected by the
people he has the authority and they
have their authority because of him this
is why if you saw the schedule f story
that axios was talking about uh trump is
talking about that if he gets reelected
he wants to set up a situation where he
can just directly fire anybody in the
federal government and completely flip
this axis on its head that sounds good
so this is this is leviathan and
huffington post was going after me for
calling this but they didn't understand
what i was saying um because i said
leviathan has woken and they said oh so
big saying kraken he said they put up
like a picture of me you know give me
like side eye to something
and said that i'm calling for war and
all this and i said no no no no you
understand i'm i'm referencing hobbs
right so hobbes wrote the leviath and
leviathan is the state is this
all-powerful superstate and these people
that have been not elected not uh
transparently or openly put into
positions of power by their people as
their representatives they just exist
because of their connections because of
their ties because they have quote
unquote the right credentials the
opposite of a meritocracy you get you
get a good donation to somebody the
donor is yeah like an ambassador right
there you go yeah i got mixed feelings
on the can fire anybody at any time
clause of section what's called section
half is it why why oh because if you get
a crazy tyrant in there and they want to
fire everyone and then put cronies in
that's also a reason you still have a
congress
yeah the the the executive branch should
be under the command of the executive
branch the idea that we elect the person
to run the executive branch but then
bureaucratic civil servants
block that like the fact that donald
trump was like i want to get our trips
out of syria and then this who was it it
was a mcmaster who blocked it and said
and then lied about it right
so that's a problem that's a big problem
we the people said this is the guy for
the job
um so and they do all this in the name
of democracy by the way that's our love
rating the rating your chief political
opponent in the name of democracy i
think that ben frankl would be horrified
at the amount of unelected power in the
american government i agree yeah i
completely agree all of the founding
fathers yeah if we if we attached a a a
turbine you know uh uh to the the graves
of the founding fathers we would solve
climate change
everyone would have a tesla after that
yeah yeah every car
okay
spinning body power yeah exactly well so
you think we should i mean do you think
a president could actually get away with
firing everybody or would they be like
actually
in in theory yes you can fire everyone
but
why shouldn't he
oh i mean
de facto do you think it would actually
happen or do you think someone would
assassinate the guy
well i mean just from a practical
perspective i mean you'd have to do
rolling firings right you wouldn't be
able to get rid of everyone in the u.s
government at once sorry libertarians
by the way
i mean you technically but you but i do
think it's the outcome you want i do
think it's funny that you get these um
when they do the government shutdowns
and everyone's like oh the government's
shut down the government shut down and
then it's like did you notice yeah i
think did anything actually mean
hopefully all it meant is that like you
know happen people in the army aren't
getting paid so how would you prevent if
we were to do a rolling fire of a lot of
the administrative state for something
like the bath party not to happen again
how when we went into iraq we fired a
bunch of saddam's old party and then we
said you can never work in politics no
you went under your house you've got it
backwards we've got the bath party now
that's the truth now that's my concern
when we've got rid of the bath party
when we fired them all and said you
can't work in politics again
they kind of join the taliban hear me
out
you buy greenland
you transfer them all to greenland well
how do we stop them from forming like an
underground political movement is my
question what do you mean they've done
that but they're the ones in charge of
right now
and so when you're looking at mueller
she wrote and you're looking at the
resistance and you're looking at
the attorney general just came out and
publicly stated that he ordered a raid
on the president's the former
president's personal residence that's
what's that's the situation we're in
right now
i just want to stress like and these
people didn't bat and i they cheered it
this is something
that in other countries people have
explained they've fled the country over
oh yeah when an administration comes in
and then starts arresting and raiding
the homes of the of their of their
political opponents there are people who
are like that's when i decided to leave
the country it's like we're all sitting
here like well so if you're in like a
post-soviet state or venezuela or cuba
or um
you know parts of the middle east you'd
be like oh yeah that's normal yeah well
we know what's coming next right like if
we were to fire or if the president were
to fire this modern iteration of the
bath party or whatever you want to
consider like what would stop them from
forming an underground political
movement of violent extremism like the
taliban because that's what they did in
iraq they just kind of joined the
taliban well we're not iraq
yeah it's it's very different here i
think the bigger issue is they'll do
what they're already doing which is
controlling weapons it's it's money
collusion
things like contact all their all their
foreign
you start with the ses level so that
senior executive service and then you
just go down the gs list yes 15 gs14
gs13 just go all the way down and for
anyone who's not politically appointed
so first of all when you're coming in as
a new administration you've got to get
rid of all the political appointees that
was something that trump didn't do the
first time around obama did it of course
obama did it and then uh and they got
they they yelled at trump for starting
to do this no get rid of all the
political appointees whether you're you
know the secretary the assistant
secretary the dazdy whatever it is go on
all of you and then and then everyone
else switch them over to schedule f and
basically tell have them come in and you
know it's like that scene in office
space you know explain to us why you
should continue working here
kurt schlichter said that same it's very
similar thing that's what's great i love
her
and then he's wrong about desantis so as
the president would the president be the
one that he loves it oh is the president
the one that would be listening to
everybody that comes in is this like or
would he appoint like people to listen
how amazing there would be a process
there would be a process of consultants
what would you say you do here i got it
i know how we can fix the budget deficit
yes lower the national debt yes and get
rid of the bureaucratic state yes we
film donald trump reviewing each
employee and then we do like charges we
do like a court show music like
and it's like jerry smith is the uh
senior accountant in you know for the
irs is coming in to trump to justify his
position and trump's sitting there and
he's like so what do you do here uh well
um i've been here for five years and
then it's like you go to commercial and
then we do we do promos make a ton of
money dude
trump you're fired boom and then they
they'll do like a rubber stamp on the
screen
you just add a button next to the red
button it's like i guess black right so
the black button would be you're fired
so people pay 10 bucks a month to watch
and then we can cut taxes because we're
making the money through subscriptions
through voluntarism yes okay a white
house like streaming service where trump
just filed everybody would watch that
the white house needs a streaming
service yes please so this is something
that during the administration and
um scaramucci actually when he was there
something that he he had
um
suggested something that he'd pitched to
the white house was you should run this
like a reality tv show and i said that
from the start i know cernovich said
that we were telling them just have
cameras in here all that or as much as
much as possible that it won't you know
you won't get you into like legal or
actually obviously classified
information but all of those little
scenes i remember they did this
really early on and you would see you
know ivanka would go in and then the
grandkids would be there and trump just
kind of hanging out with them because
the biggest issue with donald trump's
candidacy and and just just
whatever you call his public image right
now is that they paint him as a monster
the same thing alex jones and the way
that you fight that is you show the
humanity you show the human side you
show them with their family you show
them with their grandkids show alex with
his kids um and just just bring the
camera in jackie onassis did this when
she was the first lady and it was one of
the first times anyone had ever actually
seen what the inside of the west wing
and the residence and the east wing and
what all of this was like the more you
show of that then it won't matter what
crazy things they say about you because
people can see it with their own eyes
exactly
yeah so that's that's you know i talked
to a lot of people about the ad stuff
that we've done
and there's i don't understand why yeah
i mean i like what you guys do here but
i don't understand why more people don't
do just like engage the traditional
spaces take them over like daily wire
obviously gets it yeah diy they do a
great job but there's a lot of
independent and right-wing media that
revel in being outsiders that are not a
part of the system and i'm like
you need to be like you need to go in
there and then just be the thing and
convince people this is normal what
we're doing is the thing you know what i
mean
yeah and that's something that over at
so we're you know we do human events
daily through turning point usa and
there's there's a bunch new shows that
are coming out there um there's a new
talk show called rent free there's a
great show called reloaded coming out
it's actually it kind of got revamped it
was more of a talk show at first now
it's going to be more of like like a
pawn stars type show
pedro is hosting that we have poplitex
we've spilled over alex clark and it's
it's just this idea of creating your own
content whether it be
you know and you can break the fourth
wall you can be normal you can have
conversational shows like this and just
have normal people having actual
conversations instead of the
pre-scripted um you know talking points
or the screaming matches and the debates
that never really seem to go anywhere
you can do that and that's how you can
bring together people from different
sides of the aisle different sides of
the country wherever and actually have a
conversation
yeah that's what you need
picturing like in the white house you
hear people in the hallway talk kind of
like the office imagine if trump had a
podcast in the white house and you'd
even hear you see people talking and
then you'd hear like what no
no and it's trump yelling from the other
room and the people are like looking at
the camera that would be the most
entertaining stuff even the people that
hate him would love to watch that he'd
make ton of money yeah imagine if they
funded the whole us budget off of just
like a reality tv show about trump
because everyone in the world wants to
watch it you easily could
there's no bigger dollars you need
there's no bigger rate well you'd have
to cut the fed at that point but hey hey
bannon just went out at cpac
and said and you don't usually hear
bannon say this he comes right up to it
but he finally crossed the line and said
and the fed he said don't
don't audit it abolish it and the cpac
crowd at the donut the cattlemen's ball
donor dinner in dallas texas applauded
abolishing the server he said there's
don't audit it that's interesting don't
audit it abolish it a meme i saw i love
it and it says all roads lead to it it
has all the roads coming to one sp like
all these streets yeah and that says ron
paul was right about everything oh i saw
that one yeah yeah yeah that's just like
that ron paul poster outside my door
last week i opened my door and it was
ron paul standing in front of me this
giant life-sized poster of them someone
slid it over that was actually me oh
nice job well there's that great ron
paul clip when we played it on the show
earlier this week from from 1988 and
he's talking about the fbi and he points
out he said
we didn't have these things you know
prior to world war one yeah these are
not you know long-standing american
institutions and you know to everybody
out there who's a fan of like scully and
mulder and booth and bones and mind
hunter and whatever you know criminal
minds and all these different shows that
ain't what it's like in real life we're
seeing what it's like in real life right
now so
civil war
uh you're talking of course about the
avengers series right yeah yeah yeah
avengers civil war yeah yeah yeah man so
what's next what's next for this great
nation pickle jars presidents uh biden
gets another four years or what what are
we doing debt recall can we have gone
kimmel and do like a math test or like a
reading test see what happens
what would you have them do remember
that thing that breathing tests
trump took the cognition test whatever
yeah that purple monkey dishwasher is
that what it was or what no it was like
it was like circle hammer alien
yeah and trump was like i did it so well
i did it better than everyone everybody
cognition
uh we're coming up on biden's 80th
birthday in november we're waiting for
uh his health report too right his
doctor's supposed to release one every
year i think yeah they're going to come
out and be like he's great he's in great
health yeah
yeah he's too good of health actually
he's too healthy we need him to slow
down and take a break and maybe go home
for a little bit and have some cheetos
or something but that's exactly what
they did that's exactly what they did
it look at the timing though of this of
the mar-a-lago raid right
biden gets kind of pushed off the main
stage he's gone kamala harris nowhere to
be found and then all of a sudden this
raid just comes out of nowhere
absolutely out of nowhere you wake up
you know i think i guess the news came
out the middle of the day on monday of
this week and it would trump broke the
story actually funny enough um or not
funny enough you know anything about the
guy that he says they're raiding
mar-a-lago and of course of course the
same way by the way trump is the one who
actually broke the story that trump's
campaign was spied on um that original
tweet i just found out they were tapping
the wires in trump tower now it wasn't
directly correct about that but he's
pretty close in terms of what they were
doing in fact it was actually worse
because they had spies inside his
campaign it's almost like trump was
never really the president and what i
mean by that is the institutions and the
bureaucratic state sealed him off from
as much as possible so that he couldn't
do anything well have you seen yes
minister
so the entire plot of yes minister is
basically what we're talking about and
it's this 1970 sitcom set in in the uk
and if this new government comes in and
they want reform and they want
transparency and they say we're going to
we're really going to change the way
things are around here we want open very
first episode just give you an example
very first episode they say we want
reform we want openness and we want
transparency and of course all the and
then so all the other main characters
are members of the bureaucracy the
remember or the civil service as it's
called in the uk and so you know
permanent undersecretary and these
different things and
you know they've all got their great
titles and they say okay so you want
reform and openness and transparency
okay all right great and so they go leak
his his schedule to like the local
tabloids
and then of the minister yeah and then
he goes wait a minute why did you leak
my personal schedule everyone i'm
meeting with is out here you said you
wanted openness and transparency we're
just giving you that there you go and
then so every episode is him trying to
do something but those guys just
screwing him over right pictures of his
butt
they can do anything you said a couple
what i'm just saying hey transparency
you want to see it all uh let's start
with your butt uh so you saw a couple
episodes ago that you thought if the
americans went off the us dollar as the
world currency would be just tragedy uh
i think you alluded to it maybe i don't
wanna put words in your mouth well no i
i think that um
i think that people talk about ending
the us dollar as if it'll be painless
and i just don't think that's true i've
been thinking a lot about a debt recall
right now because tim asked earlier
what's next and i other than like okay
well we got to fix the economy that's
what's next but how uh a debt currency
recall where like for two years you have
the opportunity to turn your u.s your
federal reserve promissory note in and
you get back like 20 80 of the money you
turn into scale up the more dollars you
turn in the less you get back
uh does that
but who's going to allow that yeah then
the people with all the dollars in in
the cayman islands or in panama are
going to be like well i can't even
acknowledge that i have these dollars so
i don't want this to happen the federal
reserve's not going to want it to happen
no they will continue so we're basically
at the point and you saw this this bill
this inflate inflation reduction act
which would expand why would they why
would they need an inflation reduction
there was no inflation because there is
no inflation right why didn't they just
call it the deflation that we're
basically at the point where
we're at the point where they're just
raiding the treasury where they kind of
know that the whole thing is going to
fall over so it's about how much money
can you get out before the whole thing
just collapses and so that's what this
is it's just handouts to
all their buddies handouts to the unions
hands out to the donors they're stealing
whatever silverware from the titanic as
it sinks yes
and then that's why i'm saying like what
do you el salvador
you know they recently introduced
bitcoin and everything's been going
really well for them el salvador the u.s
government wants to install a little
freedom down there and then install a
little freedom yeah here comes this goes
to the bald eagle that's why they're
installing a little freedom down
mar-a-lago way yeah yeah stalling
freedom iraq's free now and so is
afghanistan um
so i don't i mean
they want to indict trump oh yeah they
actually and you know to go back to what
we were originally talking about they
actually want to indict
donald trump they tried to and they
wanted more than impeachment they wanted
impeachment and conviction and they
couldn't get it so now they're going
this route and i just i just have to
keep saying you know and i'm sure
there's not many people that are you
know in the biden regime that are
watching this but if you've stumbled in
here um please don't do this pl please
not not from a perspective of um you
know i'm worried about you know his
legal chances or anything because it's a
joke right it's obviously a joke that
none of this stuff applies to the
president but
you are putting this country on a
terrible path and i don't want that to
happen to my country
i really don't i just think about all
these historical stories of
prominent charismatic individuals who
get locked up and then when they get out
take over
and it doesn't go the way these people
think it's going to go in there right we
have that hitler that's really
concerning we have a lot of people not
just him we have two doors right
napoleon yeah we have two doors right
now right and and and one door is
it's the republic and it's the rule of
law and it's the constitution and the
way we've been doing things
and the other door is just it's raw
naked
power
and bolshevism just straight up
bolshevism and
you're looking at a situation where very
similar and mystery grove uh who i've
talked about here before
um outlines this and if you read always
with honor by um by peter rangel he he
writes this in the fall of
imperial russia and the takeover of the
bolsheviks that it wasn't like this
immediate thing and so there were
reformers that went throughout the
society and they were saying things like
well
you know these violent criminals we
shouldn't just be locking them away we
really just want to reform them and
prison is actually the wrong place for
them and so what we should do is not
lock away the violent criminals but just
try to find special ways for them to
have programs for reform and then
reintroduce them into society right but
if you got caught with a knife well
you're going away you're going down and
that was a hundred years ago in russia
we're seeing the exact exact same things
come out here in america i've been
thinking about a mass pardon that i
think maybe is the only way forward and
i'm talking about like the last 200
years of crap all of it just non-violent
i mean i don't so this is the question
we talked about last night a little you
pardon everybody joe biden for his
misdealings in iraq fine hillary clinton
for getting us into libya and working
with sydney blumenthal's osprey global
solutions barack obama you want to talk
about george bush's illegal war in iraq
uh lying to us
because it because i want the people
from january 16th thing out of prison
right yeah but that like called the
hostage transfer trade hostages like
this seems like the most terrible but
but hold on like
like like joe biden's corrupt hillary
clinton's corrupt barack obama's corrupt
george w bush is corrupt clinton is
corrupt bush senior is corrupt
i'm fine with all of them being indicted
and how the council
yeah but we're like on the sideline like
yeah like it's a game that's not how
powerful the game well it's not like you
can't just like oh yay clap clap the
power the leaders of the power are now
gone like that's not also suggesting
pardoning people who
have actually harmed other people like
how would you feel if you were like well
this is what we have to do like you were
directly impacted by one of their
decisions and
someone else is like well but this is
how we start over we're just gonna
pardon everyone like that doesn't seem
like justice to me and it doesn't seem
like a long-term solution you're just
gonna let put a vacuum in where someone
else comes in to be corrupt and do the
same thing maybe but i'm not i'm not
condoning future crime if someone does
it in the future they're going away why
are you pardoning everyone else one
thing there's one thing it's not about
everyone being like we're going to
pardon everybody that's not a sign of
good faith at all no that's not until a
sign of good faith would be if biden
came out and said we're going to be
releasing the january 6 defendants
because we're trying to make things yeah
but what i don't want to do is like oh
you did that now i'll pardon you joe
it's not a tip for tad i'm not playing
that game i'm jack tyre saying not to do
i'm saying
one way to de-escalate things right now
if joe biden came out and said january 6
was abhorrent but we're seeing dangerous
escalation of the rhetoric between
what was described as the left and the
right and as a sign of good faith i want
to pardon these men wow and i want to
ask for forgiveness and find a way for
this country to move forward the right
would have no response other than thank
you yeah the left would be would be like
aren't we noble and gracious yeah he
would just be like oh okay i mean wow
thank you yes
or or or by the way if biden could say
could just say one nice thing to the
mother of ashley babbitt
how about i'm i'm so sorry that happened
that was a crazy day
and
i i'm sure your daughter meant well and
things got completely out of hand and i
and i'm so sorry that you lost your
daughter he's all he has to say ian's
brother would cost him nothing ian's
brought up shea's rebellion several
times yeah where it was john hancock
right yeah hancock was the governor i
think it was massachusetts he pardoned
all of these people he did a couple of
them 400 farmers and that's they didn't
have the money so it's the irs is going
to start going to people to get tax
money that they don't have they're going
to be throwing people in jail it's going
to be similar to shay's rebuilding whoa
they didn't talk about i read that
description it did that
uh oh yeah the job description they did
not say anything about throwing people
into jail they didn't put that in there
they said shoot to kill
let me explain something to everybody
they keep saying in the media the irs is
not going to audit lower income people
and they are correct the irs is not
going to audit lower income people
they're just going to send you the bill
this is what people don't get about
taxes
the narrative is cleverly manipulated by
the democrats who are like no we're not
going to audit you don't worry and they
go oh okay you're not gonna cause that's
a formal audit because what the irs does
is three months after you file you get a
letter in the mail saying you owe us two
thousand seven hundred ninety six
dollars and twenty three cents you can
pay it here there's no audit they just
tell you you owe them money right are
you going to call a lawyer no you're bro
if the irs can add 87 000 people
all they have to do is send a letter to
every tax paying american you actually
owe us 10 bucks more and what are you
gonna do about it you're just gonna give
it ten bucks or you're not if you can't
if you don't have it and that's what
happened with shay's rebellion is they
didn't have the money they couldn't they
just didn't have the money and so they
didn't pay they they were gonna seize
their farms so they went to the farm the
to the courthouse and and
you know did basically january 6 on the
courthouse and said no you're not taking
our farms a bunch of people went in
prison for years eventually john hancock
was like we're we're tearing the union
what happened was the local police
wouldn't stop the farmers they're like
no they have the they don't have the
money so they called in the the state
police to take care from the state
police didn't know who they were so they
threw them in jail then hancock was like
the only way forward is is pardoning and
moving forward
if joe biden pardoned the j6 defendants
it would be
his popularity would probably skyrocket
i think i think that would be a great
move towards de-escalation but there is
one other way that doesn't even involve
pardons if you can design if you want
actual de-escalation
in this party
and in this country i think actual dls
de-escalation we can get the escalation
if everyone would just get
the best night's sleep in the whole wide
world
with mypillar.com promo code so that
you've got the toppers you've got the
sheets you got the pillows then when you
wake up you got the slippers now we have
the my coffee mystory.com mysore.com
promo code post so think of it now you
can be awake as much as mike lindell
ladies and gentlemen this entire episode
was a setup for jack to do a commercial
i really appreciate you because we went
over the script scripted it yeah so so
much beforehand and that was actually
the end of the script so we have a
little bit of time for like super chat
what are we talking about now before we
move on i want to talk about how
important rest is for the human body and
that getting a good pillow might
actually be a great idea ian totally
missed his line on that um particularly
from my post so i'm sorry i'm getting
this all wrong oh my god my pillow.
where do i get one of your can we cast
the new intent can we cast
so i want to figure out is is is
authorizing violence the same as doing
violent is that violent crime
authorizing a violent crime wait what
i'm done with this guy let's just move
on what's next wait no we've got super
chances we are not authorizing violence
no like like george bush authorized
people to go commit violence if that
violence is talking about market
reprisal like privateers were
told by the crown or by the government
yeah okay we're fine with pi and they
kind of washed their hands of it so
until until a certain point when they
pulled the letters of mark and then said
okay you're all outlaws now when right
when it became that's how privateers
became that's how pirate like the actual
real life the pirates of the caribbean
became pirates they were all working for
the british to begin with to go after
the spanish galleons because the british
said we don't want our navy to do it you
guys just go do it and we'll let you do
that and then keep whatever you want so
they did that but then the war ended and
then they said okay if you continue to
do this you're all you know you're all
criminals now
wild yeah crazy days all right let me
see
we're having this weird problem where
youtube's keep keeps crashing i'm
looking forward to the same time every
day too all right we're going to super
chats if you haven't already would you
please smash that like button subscribe
to this channel and share the show with
your friends check out the uncensored
tim cast irl stuff monday through
thursday at 11pm over at timcast.com and
check out tales from the inverted world
cass castle will be coming up next week
tuesday this time for sure and then it's
going to be every week so we're going to
have a lot of fun it's uh it's going to
be really funny stuff we did we filmed
with jack today it was it was good stuff
i won't spoil anything but we didn't
film that that was real that was real
you're right uh we filmed with marjorie
taylor green and zooby and uh we're
getting a lot of people involved and
having a good time do you film with
santorum
uh no no no so funny funny backstory my
first ever job in politics was field
director for rick santorum 2006. oh wow
look at that there you go
all right raymond g stanley jr with the
first super chat says po so the my
pillow like button i just i just need a
button so so a button in front of me
that um what well how does that work
then do i buy you the pillow and then we
should know you buy me the pillow we
should get you by yourself we should get
you a stream deck yes with one button
yes plays a sound bite that when you
press it it says buy pillow by pillow
buy pillow buy pillow buy pill buy
pillow so i noticed that raymond g ma
stanley jr took the maga out of his name
and i just wanted to mention maga month
ended july is over i was pretty sad to
see it go well so i changed my profile
pictures back i actually i got an angry
email
that was like
you only cared about maga for one month
and then you changed your profile back
because you don't care about america i
thought it was funny because the the the
point of the joke was to mock the people
who claimed to care about a cause but
then abandoned it right away right
that's why i was like oh it's months
over like the american flag's out now
but whatever
i looked at it like christmas right you
could celebrate christmas in december
and then you put your decorations away
yeah i like leaving the christmas lights
up till like july maybe all year well we
do well we do the whole christmas tied
so we do we do little christmas so
that's we take them down uh which is
january 6th which is old old christmas
oh wow and then because my wife oh yeah
yeah so my wife is orthodox so we
actually celebrate both oh wow all right
logan roldan says just built my new bed
in my new rural town in eastern oklahoma
glad i got out of that hell whole state
of california and holy ish gun law is
not a thing out here and can buy my drum
mags but do you need pillows for your
new bed oh that probably does probably
oh yeah that sounds awesome
and a topper and sheets and all the rest
we really do use them by the way
get tanya on here some night she'll
she'll tell you we got rid of all the
pillows she got rid of all the pillows
in her house and was like i want all
pine pellets i bought the slippers you
got the slippers those were legit those
you know we um they have all seasons and
uh slippers now oh so they did because
they because people kept saying that
they were wearing them outside and then
so the idea was well we need to make
them just a little bit more rugged yeah
so that you can wear them outside and
that's the new all seasons legit i will
say whatever whatever's inside them is
the fluffiest thing yeah what makes them
so good uh it's it's actually uh clouds
and dreams
[Laughter]
that you're just walking directly on
them the coffee thing though it's like
everybody's selling coffee these days
you know what i mean yeah it really is
it really is like everyone's doing
coffee is there like some like
conservative coffee company that's like
sourcing for all of these people who are
selling coffee so i actually i ran into
mike at cpac and i don't like text him
every day like i'm sure everybody thinks
um
in fact
um they sometimes
some of my my pillow ones they're like
hey jack that might be a little bit
close to the edge you know like i got we
got cancelled enough places already you
know we got it but he said he's gonna
save the coffee he said he's gonna send
me the coffee oh we got a good one here
steven bortlemay says all this talk of
civil war is making me lose sleep if
only there were someone that could tell
me how i can get a good night's sleep
yes that would leave me speechless like
michael nolan's book ah
very good it was it was a it turned out
like a double it was a turnaround yeah i
love how there's there's like the
sponsorships have become memes
how it's just like people were memeing
michael knowles book to get me to read
it yeah i was funny because like every
time i'm reading a super chat i'll
explain this so for those that aren't
familiar with the meme when michael
knowles's book would came out called
speechless people would start a super
chat by saying like tim what you said
about this was so profound it left me
speechless like michael's book or they'd
be like donald trump came out with these
powerful words and when he said this i
was left speechless mike but the thing
is i'm like
and then his book went number one it did
but like you're giving me money
and i'm reading it it's funny and then
michael knowles is selling his book i'm
like
this is a win
this is actually something that i think
coincided with
a few multi like a multiple you know
multi-factorial
kind of moment where
up until a couple of years ago it was
this idea that everything on the
internet is free everything on the area
is free we don't want to think we don't
like the paywall we don't want something
but then with the rise of the content
creator
it became this idea of well if i support
my creator my favorite creator if i
support someone that i like watching or
i like reading
then i get more of them and they get to
continue to do what they do and say and
and you know what 10 bucks a month isn't
that bad right and so
you now see people that are so much more
willing to do that than they ever were
before right
so we got uh john kersten says with
hannah claire and ghost girl as regulars
i no longer care luke went for six and
never came back or that potato guy being
gone
good we don't need them luke went for
six and never came back
that's that's about right one friday
just now and then seamus just
disappeared one day we don't know what
happened just one day he was here then
he was gone
that's how leprechauns work
oh i've got my intel and sheamus don't
worry on sheamus i've got intel on all
of you
we're waiting for our everyone to come
back oh for everybody to come back
then we'll all sit at the chair once
we'll just rotate around the room
all right let's see
caleb cass says if the senate doesn't
pass the budget next month the health
and climate bill gets no funding
but they're going to why wouldn't they
yeah i mean that that stuff's gonna it's
it's all gonna get passed yeah
i like how the left is making fun of uh
they're they're they're they're making
fun of bernie there's a meme going
around on leftists where it's like joe
manchin smiling saying
uh co-wrote or co-sponsored one of the
most comprehensive climate bills and
then bernie like got nothing past in 30
years
and that like
i i i saw that and that i thought it was
hilarious five mansions
five minutes does he have five
um
he might be up to five now because he
did vote for the uh the inflation
reduction
for the spending
bill all right excuse me says ian tell
poso how you want to let dem politicians
go free from prosecution for betraying
the american people and republicans
well we i think we
got into that part of it is i i i think
that a lot of their crimes are being
just dismissed right now people aren't
really acknowledging some of it so if we
pardoned them then we would at least
acknowledge it which is like the best i
think we can get
rebel without a cause says hi i'm the
journalist known formerly as tim poole
since changing my diet to keto i've also
changed my name i am now slim pool oh
there you go
slim
and by the way
for the record i'm pretty sure garland's
going to get impeached
oh yeah marjorie taylor green filed
articles so she she filed it but um this
isn't gonna be until january this isn't
one of one of those ones where
you know it's like you file it and then
it just sits there but it's a big press
release and you know nothing really
happens no he's getting impeached he's
absolutely getting impeached in the new
congress what do you think your charges
are what are they uh they are going to
charge him for for corruption they're
going to charge him for
uh completely unconstitutional action
they'll they'll find a direct charge but
this raid on mar-a-lago
this raid on mar-a-lago has turned so
many people that were independents that
were moderates we're hearing it from
donors as well saying
you know
we thought trump was
um just being you know office not office
rocker we thought he was crazy we
thought some of these things that he was
saying were nuts
and you just raided mar-a-lago they just
proved him right like you just proved
him right so it means that trump will
probably be the nominee now right
there's like no question about that and
he's at at this point and i said this on
twitter the other day donald trump will
be the next president united states all
right jacob cahill says today is my 38th
birthday and i can't think of a better
gift to myself than a shout out from tim
and the gang thank you for creating the
best live journalism show in the world
much love happy birthday jacob thank you
for watching and supporting the work we
do nice job i hope you have a good
birthday man somebody buy that man a
pillow might pull it buy him a pillow
i'd say buy him a drink for his birthday
but a pillow works as well
seth hauser says after everything the
democrats have done there should be no
pardons for these criminals they have
done too much damage if they go to jail
so be it
i mean keep in mind that
look i just sat in the courtroom when
steve bannon was was on trial
for this this paper argument
um that they were having about which was
also about separation of powers this
executive privilege
they put him on show trial
there they may put steve bannon in jail
over this and so this is my response to
ian is they're already putting
republicans in jail
that's how bad this is mandalore wise
says main reason i think the cincy thing
was a false flag is the claims that viva
fry told people or told him to be
violent so go guard mar-a-lago anyone
who watches viva is calling bs
so that's just false viva never said
that vivo like passively read a comment
where he's like oh i guess people are
going to mar-a-lago
and then this guy posts like viva frey
is saying things are happening but if
you watch the actual clip and so usa
today wrote this uh
this attack piece on viva because the
guy referenced him and so they said oh
this guy said he heard it from viva fray
even though he didn't go to mar-a-lago
which is what the whole thing was about
yeah and if you actually watch the clip
and viva has this up on his timeline he
said he's reading this comment and then
he says oh yeah you shouldn't do that
don't go to don't go down there so he
even says it that that's you know that's
a bad idea don't it's just weird smears
but they cut that off
man weird they smear what they fear they
smear what they fear yeah waffle sense
it says ian it's not that jfk's brain
was officially recorded as missing it's
just that the brain that was included in
the autopsy report was virtually
undamaged make of it what you will oh
okay
well
i don't know about all that stuff as
well before i was like maybe it was in
his brain i think was the
theory no it's just in dallas and i
didn't go to the grassy knoll oh have
you been there have you been to the
sixth floor museum negative it's great i
haven't spent i haven't spent much time
at all's oh dallas is super cool i love
dallas i had i was there it was you know
cpac work work work when you see back
it's hard because it's just like you
have to be somewhere all day long
elijah shafer's show but you you
teleprompted you tell a viewed in didn't
you so i've done eliza show in person in
the past but then i was down for a
better discourse so we had to go
straight to that and then yeah when i
did elijah show this week i was on that
was from here uh from dc got it
and for some reason they made me look
like this golden bronze
yes well it's hard not going on look at
yourself yeah i know well for here we
apply the filter to make me look human
you were the fireman that tim wanted
earlier right that's true success
about me kane iv says need liberty prime
if a war with china comes
i'm a big fan of liberty prime what is
that from fallout 3 is a giant robot the
americans built that to fight communism
and as it like it's activated just like
communism is bad or yelling something
like that it's funny
taiwan should just start mine in the
streets
waffle sensei says i think the best
course for china and russia who have
been using ideological subversion
against into civil war is for russia to
fund the right china to run the left and
both fund our destruction
so this was a russian state tv said
these their pundits said that um a civil
war was probably coming and the only
question is who which side do they fund
with an armed with weapons
who do you think i i
who would russia give weapons to
obviously not biden
if a civil war broke out no we'll give
it to like pro-communists
russia and china would work together and
then you'd have europe working
we don't have to consider this because
we we just found out that there was a
there was a russian-backed group down in
florida that just got totally rolled up
and it was a it was a group of black
separatists
oh well this is a good one celebrant
says completely russian funded jack
could you talk about pizza hut
nationalism i've been thinking about it
a bit recently how can we get back to
those days we've we've talked about that
on the show before when i was on i think
and a salad bar yeah so you had the
salad bar you had this this idea that
pizza hut wasn't just a place that
delivered pizza that it was actually a
communal space where you could go
and spend time
as a kid you had book it you had and
then i had taken my kids to a pizza hut
near where we lived and it was just it
was atrocious it was dirty and
disgusting and if it's a standalone
building at all at this point they're
just like we're trying to get out of
there it's it's a strip mall pizza today
is a strip mall you walk up you open the
door there's like two chairs and you
order the food you leave well so this
was it was an old pizza hut which is why
i initially had thought it was a place
you could go and sit let's bring it back
let's make our own let's do it we'll do
it out here we'll do it we'll we'll
we'll uh
we'll call it pizza shack pizza shack
done yeah done and you had that idea
that idea before do you remember your
idea about
i forget it was a hotel or a hangout
spot but it was like uh the different
living rooms from different eras yeah do
you remember this idea so uh my an idea
i've had for a while is to uh and
i mean maybe we should just do it and
this is something that we might need
like an investor for a developer you get
a building and you create uh you get one
bedroom uh apartments and you can get
maybe what should we do should we do
like six of them
and you've got you go in one and it's
the 1990s everything in it will be
stocked from the 90s tvs from the 90s
when you turn the tv on it's nice tv
it's pre-programmed with like a specific
date from the 90s maybe like 1992 or
something then you've got the 80s room
the 70s the 60s and the 50s did 92 have
a vertical i want urkel i don't think it
had oracle 192.
no i need urkel wait so what is this
like a museum or is it like an airbnb
it's a hotel it's like a hotel the idea
is that you could book a a a it's a
theme
hotel where boutiques are yeah you you
you'll be like i want to i want to be in
the 90s and you'll go and be like a
radio you'll turn it on and we'll just
pre-program everything to play on a loop
so it's like live streaming basically if
you order room service do you only get
snacks prepared from that era yes and
when you open the fridge there will be
like leftover with the same box from
that era you can just call it eras
yeah errors we we'd be sold out every
night i guess oh yeah it'd be like a
different hotel every time you went i
got to imagine there's got to be a place
in vegas like this it would be have they
not done this already i want to stay i
want to be able to be like i want to
spend the night in the 70s for example
look it's like a vinyl player i mean
look at 50 designers right 50s diners
are everywhere everybody loves these
things they're still popular today and
the most popular ones are the ones that
best recreate the 1950s experience yeah
and then you know you have but you'll
also have like entertainment and news so
like if you're in the 50s place you can
turn the tv on and hear about like the
politics of the day civil rights stuff
like that the 60s there's the moon
landing in the 90s at the fall of the
soviet union or you can just watch the
honeymooners or something it'd be cool
you like turn the knob on the tv or if
you go to the 40s there is no tv right
it's just radio no tv yeah is it kind of
like after 2000 like society just
homogenized no no no man like you you go
in the 2000s one and they're gonna have
like avril lavigne yeah avril lavigne
it's gonna have all that stuff it's
gonna have like a poster for final
destination or whatever and that's the
movie that's on tv
and then we just have one room that's
like a like a normal hotel room for
today confirmed steve urkel was
definitely around 92. really yeah you're
gonna get your family matters first wait
i mean the person or the show well
family matters the show 89 and 97.
family members started 89. wow
what's that
song
we got to do this so um
i i have no idea how to start a hotel
you know but it's an idea so uh someone
should do it because i'd love to stay
there i don't know right i totally do
amazing yeah 90s and you've got you've
got no but hey we should do a pizza
shack you've got your you've got league
of
legends
nintendo 64 all over the place they've
all got golden eye because what other
game is there yeah golden eye no
foreign i was talking about doing like a
sandwich spot or something let's make a
let's let's make a building like it's a
rectangular building you go in it's got
booth seating it's got the pizza bar and
salad bar in the middle and we'll do a
reading program at the local school and
if you're a local little league team
um you know maybe you you get a discount
you eat for free
all that stuff yeah we'll contact the
local schools and we'll make our own
book program yeah well
all of that stuff the teacher will be
like read the book and then you can get
the thing and come in for a pizza
instead of book it we could call it book
em
but it's my thing like you know you talk
about pizza and nationalism and what we
what we lost right these yeah they were
communal spaces you went there when you
went i remember that you get the wheel
or whatever for like reading books and
you get like a free donut and you get
like a p free slice like a free personal
pizza i read all those books too yeah i
always read those books my friends would
be there i'd show i'd be like oh it's my
friends from school because when they
were handed out because they were there
too that's what we need to bring back
man
have you heard about my idea for
saturday morning cartoons negative
so we're looking for venues right now in
eastern west virginia i love saying that
oh yeah
what we want to do is like gaming
skating hangout spot just whatever but
then on saturday mornings we want to
play cartoons so that parents can bring
their kids to hang out there will be
like a breakfast buffet with like
sausage eggs bacon pancakes waffles and
the parents can hang out and talk to
each other in the morning and the kids
all get to you know play games while
watching these shows and it's a way to
create kind of like a secular community
community event because it used to be
the church and i was like not everybody
goes to church some people still go to
church a lot of people don't let's bring
people together with saturday morning
cartoons not bad and then it's also
because it also doesn't conflict with
church we right exactly in fact many
people might actually
meet people there and then decide to go
or
the big issue is
the parents are involved in the content
the kids will watch so it's like you're
not getting these weird shows from
disney or something you're getting like
the approved shows i always love those
goofy cartoons from like the 60s and 50s
disney where he's like there's the
narrator talking like and then he walks
to figure out how to dig a hole that's
hilarious one shovel thing at a time
have you guys ever seen those old
fantastic disney no saint says tim
should do one segment every day using a
v tuber model then he could have a fan
art tag on twitter
yeah what what if i had like uh an anime
waifu v tuber and then i used a voice
changer and just did a normal segment so
it's just like an anime waifu with like
a sexy female voice telling you the news
i bet it would make way more money
people keep asking me for i i keep
getting hit up by these freaking weebs
man and they all want my pillow waifus
and it ain't happening it is not
happening no weave go back to your crawl
spaces
i don't know man every freaking day man
okay
el rojo grande says tim it seems pretty
obvious to me what happened here trump
declassified those documents as he said
the biden admin probably reclassified
those documents to use a pretext to
attack trump is that it's not is that
allowed no i don't yeah i don't think
that makes sense that works
i think they're just
fishing you can't triple stamp a double
stamp you can't you know it's like it's
like
i'm sorry we're gonna we're gonna push
our entire republic to the precipice of
civil war over an argument about
document markings really
really
because we know that's not what this is
about right can we can we all just
drop all that i think they want donald
trump to not be able to run for office
right when you said debatification when
you reference that that's exactly what
they're trying to do they want
de-trumpification
anyone who's associated with him anyone
in his family anyone who gave him money
anyone who voted for him anyone who's a
public supporter they want you gone they
want you erased it's tantalizing but
referenced the bath party becoming the
taliban or joining the taliban as a
result of being barred from politics
don't do it again because history does
rhyme right but
the which is different from the deep
state though if you're a bureaucrat
maybe you should be elected maybe you
should have to go through some kind of
public process to get these why
shouldn't dr fauci be someone that's
subject to public review in a freaking
tournament man
yes
chance terry says jack tim many
thousands including myself are facing
discharge over military coveted vaccine
mandate so trump has talked about this
please be our voice because we don't
have one we need your help our readiness
is being decimated trump has said this
straight up and that's the one thing
where you have to say like if if the
vaccines are your issue and or if you
have someone who's in
your family uh if it's you right he's
the only politician that i've heard
anywhere in america just total free
money say if i'm elected i will
reinstate every single one of these
members with back pay and by the way i
would also say because if you're on the
enlisted side you have time and grade
promotions i would hope that he would
also add the time and grade promotions
along with that because every this we
treat our troops like trash over this
like straight up trash you joined the
military you raised your right i'm a
veteran you raised your hand and you
said i will do whatever my country asked
of me and then we're going to knock you
out because you don't want to take
something no that's it's it's one of the
most
just disgraceful moments of our entire i
mean it reminds me of some of these you
know the bonus army and some of these
things even the bonus army was kind of a
kami plot but
you know it's
how can you treat actively serving
members of our military like this i
don't understand it simulation says in
response to drafting females
aren't a majority of military roles
today support roles and non-combat roles
is it a majority there's a lot i mean
i
i'd have to look at the numbers for the
army i mean certainly in the navy right
you know or the air force right that's
why they call it the chair force as a
joke not you know not knock on the chair
force guys but you know obviously the
majority people in the air force are not
pilots right so the idea then is you
know is everyone going to be a in a
combat role and that's kind of the thing
people think of the military at if there
is a job in the real life i guarantee
you there is a cognate to that job in
the military caper 2x says jack the
female aviator died when her tomcat lost
an engine landing on the carrier she
waited too long to eject to give her wso
time to get out
it was crazy
i mean but that sounds more like she
she would do something heroic right
god bless her yeah mechanical error not
pilot air i don't know i don't know i
have to look into that story
uh didn't the cdc just relax all these
guidelines on kovitz so does that not
kind of uh
um maybe a
indication that people are going to be
let back into the military that the
mandates are going to be lifted i don't
know man
i mean you haven't seen much
uh
self-awareness from this regime
whatsoever they don't care right they
actually don't care that they've changed
what they said denmark by the way just
dropped the vaccine for under 18. so
denmark they're doing away with it
completely
um but you're not going to see any of
that in the us they're not they're not
going to apologize for anything they've
done they don't think they did the other
problem is that thousands of military
service members applied followed they
said they were told if you apply for
religious exemption if you apply for
medical exemption we'll consider it and
their applications were rejected they
basically were told we don't actually
believe you we don't believe that you
hold these yeah it's of your values that
you don't think this uh vaccination is
something that fits with your religious
practice like that's a very hard pill to
fall to be told that we respect and
defend religious freedom except if you
enlist in the middle in the military and
you don't want uh uh
the kobe vaccine it's just crazy all
right stephen b says i'm a subscriber
but never watch the after hour because i
don't want to watch it on a lap on my
laptop is there an app or something
which it can be accessed on tv if not is
there something in developed there is
something in development
it's just uh i would love an app for
that
yeah so we are working on they're called
ott apps over the top yep we want to get
them on every tv every smart tv every
smart service and every phone and want
is uh it's a powerful word
doing yes but it requires being able to
hire a bunch of devs finding good devs
getting the work done we hired some
people to start working on development
and then they abandoned it and then the
whole thing went sour
so we are like it's one of the top
priorities that we have we've i tell
this to daily wire guys too like dude i
need your app on my tv so i can watch it
because i don't have roku or anything i
just have a smart tv i turn it on and
i'm like i want to watch daily wires
movies it's not easy to do unfortunately
because i'm a fan
same is true for us we're working on it
and hopefully soon but i don't know what
soon means man but it is a top priority
for us for sure
the jaded kriegsman says i think the
problem is that a lot of civil servants
who view their job as being to advise on
policy and not make and not make policy
but the people who get promoted into
management roles view themselves as
policy makers and act as so
yeah look i i was intelligence uh on the
civilian side and 100 percent they
believe they are the expert class they
believe they are the ones in charge they
believe that they are the ones who have
the authority and they're not they're
absolutely not that's not our system
that never was supposed to be our system
and for anybody out there who's
currently serving and real and you do
see both right you do see both in the gs
and he's 100 right that it is it does
come down to the management versus the
employees that if you're in the
leadership track you view yourself as
the policy maker and you go them and oh
i'm going to tell this congressman i'm
going to tell this president what they
should do as opposed to actually obeying
the authority and just having respect
for the authority and actual respect for
the chain of command because when i
served i was under i was under obama
right but it didn't matter you still
respect any command
all right bobcat says tim do you
remember the pizza buffet at pizza hut
that dessert pizza is something i would
invade an entire country again to bring
back
we can make we can do a gag like i'm
legit about i really would want to open
a pizza place like this finding finding
a building and everything i'm totally
down for and we should we should totally
do commercials where it's like we invade
a country to bring back
the pizza shack nationalism or do we can
we invade the past
yeah machine everyone's like what are
you doing
what's happening stand back citizen you
gotta go
you gotta say something like it's gone
wrong we have to go back don't go right
you have to go back here from the future
for your pizza where we're going we
don't need rolls
and then we bring back the building i
guess
we bring back the pizza the dough that
didn't have potassium bromate in it well
you you'll be driving around ingredients
man yeah you'll be driving around now
and you'll see
former pizza huts with like different
color schemes and different names on
them but you look at it you're like
that's a pizza hut man i don't care what
science on there that's a pizza hut my
favorite pizza fact is that it was
started by two irish brothers who had
never had pizza i find that really oh
yeah they'd never had pizza it was like
a trendy food it was coming over but it
is not authentic it's either pizza hut
or domino's started with a french bread
recipe that's what they made their crust
from really mm-hmm i could see that for
dominoes i just want to let you guys
know how much it is i am i am very upset
with how papa john's treated papa john
but if you look at the ingredients of
domino's pizza and papa john's
no questions papa john's look
ingredients are all way way better no
seriously
i think pizza put splenda in their crust
fake sugar like fake sweetener weird
cheese you look at papa john's
ingredients like wheat water do you ever
hear the story about his car
yeah yeah yeah yeah we had him on the
show oh yeah yeah right obviously found
his car again man i love that story i
love that story about him because i get
that i totally and it wasn't he he
didn't settle
for
the same make and model or even the same
way he said no i want the car was it he
sold his car when he was starting the
business to pay for it and then he
bought it when he succeeded but he found
it he tried
he's i think he put up like a bounty for
it basically and then tracked and
somebody tracked it down and and then he
bought it off them all right let's grab
one more here the bahamian rain man says
tim i'm reading about how sean hannity
is claiming that even if trump goes to
jail he can still run for potus from the
clink mr posovic do you know anything
about this
um
i mean
okay from a legal standpoint if you'd
want to get into that so the
constitution doesn't say anything it is
silent on the question of can a person
who's been uh convicted of a crime run
for president right it's not in the
constitution there are specific
qualifications that are laid out in
article two um and it doesn't mention
anything about crimes it again because
the founders trusted the people of the
states but there there is uh in the 14th
amendment i believe if you wage
insurrection
instruction but you can be convicted of
a felony and run for president so charge
them
in most states in i think every state
you can't be convicted of a felony and
run for state office but you can run for
federal office and be convicted of
themselves and this by the way that's
that's another kind of back end thing
they're trying to do if they can't get
him convicted they're going to try to
get him off the ballot anyway or you
know can't get him in prison just keep
in mind that all of these you know kind
of
scholastic arguments about this whole
thing it's and you know i think tim
you're right i think i think that this
this gets crazy way before it gets to
that point and i really don't want to go
there all right last one
ac your says i want a donald trump my
body pillow
does does it have to be an enemy my body
no you know what no just regular
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends and check out
timcast.com for our after hours on
sunsearch show monday through thursday
we are working on tv apps and a mobile
app to get all so it's a lot easier um
we we've been have like we've been
meeting about it consistently we had an
app in development it fell apart and the
company fell through is not it's not
easy to just build a company but we're
working on it we will be there we will
get there you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me at tim cast
jack you want to shout anything out uh
yeah just human events daily so we're
coming up on reel america's voice very
excited to be there be a part of that
team uh of course it's available apple
spotify wherever you get your podcast
just broke back into top 10 uh of all
apple politics uh podcast we're really
excited about that and you know you
watch us we had the irs story a week
before anybody else did wow
right on
i'm hannah clare brimmo i'm a writer for
timcast.com you can check me out there i
post almost every day as to uh do a
number of other great writers i highly
recommend it you can follow me on
instagram at hannah claire dot b i don't
remember my social media handles hankler
dot b thank you guys so much ian
crossland from ian crossland.net get
through me on social media youtube
twitter facebook minds instagram and uh
jack good stuff my man mm-hmm uh i'm
gonna do like a donald trump body pillow
hey special shout out to chris poole
holding it down hey i'm chris you can
follow me on twitter thanks for watching
everybody just pipe down man what is
this guy's deal i'll show you what is
this called yeah yeah all right
everybody thanks for hanging out go to
chickencitylive.com watch our chickens
sleep they're having a good time we're
probably gonna start eating them soon
but only only the ones we don't like
we'll we'll save the other ones thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all
next time
you